(gentle music)
I think we need to realize when we are plugged
into machinery that makes us angrier
and angrier, and angrier.
If it's enraging, it's engaging,
it will keep people scrolling.
We need an attention movement to reclaim our minds.
(gentle music)
We are not medieval peasants,
begging at the court of king Zuckerberg
for a few little crumbs of attention
from his table, right?
We are the free citizens of democracies.
We have dignity, we own our own minds
and we can take them back if we want to.
Hey everybody, welcome to the podcast.
Today, we're gonna tackle an issue
I think we can all relate to,
which is our declining ability to do something
very fundamental.
Which is to simply maintain our focus and pay attention.
It might sound silly but this is actually a growing problem
and it's not necessarily our fault.
It's a problem that's being fueled
by powerful forces incident to modern life.
And a problem I think can fairly be characterized
at this point as somewhat existential.
My guest for this discussion,
back for his second appearance on the show.
His first being RRP 416 4 years ago,
is journalist and multiple
New York Times best-selling author, Johann Hari.
Who when confronted with his own declining ability
to focus ended up spending a couple years
going really deep into the reasons why this was happening,
and the individual and systemic solutions
to this despairing trend.
Johann's books include Chasing The Scream,
which is about depression.
Lost Connections, which explores the roots of addiction,
and his latest Stolen Focus: Why You Can't Pay Attention.
Which is the basis for today's exploration
into the many forces robbing us of our attention
and a look at how we might begin
to reclaim our minds and our lives.
Johann is quite the entertaining storyteller,
I really this discussion.
So please hit that subscribe button and enjoy.
Well, I love the book you did a great job.
It's such an important issue and we're gonna get
into all of that.
But before we even like tiptoe in that direction
I have to know...
(Rich laughs)
You just did Bill Maher the other night.
We're recording this on Monday,
that's Friday night, right?
They tape on Friday night?
I didn't watch it but I listened...
'Cause they put it up as a podcast
so I was listening to it the other day.
So how was that experience?
'Cause I found him to be pretty contrarian
and a little bit cantankerous with you.
Oh no, I love Bill.
I've done Bill show like...
I know Bill well,
I've done it like six or seven times.
No, I thought he essentially...
So basically his view is our attention is fucked
but there's nothing we can do about it.
And what I was trying to say to him is you're right
our attention is fucked but we could absolutely
solve this problem.
You kept trying to sneak in solutions
and he wasn't having it.
He has a very pessimistic view of humanity's ability
to deal with this existential crisis.
Yeah, (indistinct) I get where he's coming from
and I love Bill but I don't think he's right.
I absolutely think we can solve this problem.
I hope so.
Well, that's what we're gonna talk about, right?
Hooray.
(clears throat)
It is good to see you.
Of course, you've been on the show before that was-
In the before time.
That was four years...
How long ago was that?
Four years ago.
It was four years.
Exactly four years ago.
Almost this time of year, right?
Yeah.
And I do remember when I started reading the book
and kind of a big inflection point in why you even got
interested in this subject of focus and attention
was by dent of your own struggles with your ability
to maintain focus.
And so you go to Provincetown and you dish the...
You leave the phone on the mainland
and you get an old laptop that can't connect
to the internet.
And the idea is you're gonna go three months
being completely offline.
And I believe that was in the summer of 2018, right?
Yeah, yeah.
So I remember when I was trying to book you
for the podcast and I was corresponding with...
I don't know if it was your publicist or your publisher
and they're like, "He's on an island we can't reach him."
And I was like, "All right, well, (indistinct)
(Johann and Rich laughing)
when he comes back."
So actually when you did the show
you had already had that experience, right?
So that's how long you've been working on this book.
That's so interesting.
Yeah, there were lots...
When I got back from this three months
there were lots of people.
You, Oprah had been trying to contact me
couldn't go through, right?
And no, the reason I did this is because
with each year that passed I felt for myself
like things that required deep focus
were getting more and more like running up a down escalator.
You know what I mean?
I could still do them
but they were getting harder and harder.
And I noticed this seemed to be happening
to most of the people I knew,
particularly the young people in my life.
A lot of whom seemed to be kind of worrying
at the speed of Snapchat where nothing still
or serious could touch them.
So I started looking into this.
I used my training in the social sciences
at Cambridge University to kind of begin to dig into this.
And I think the figures on this are quite shocking,
for every one child who was identified
with serious attention problems when I was seven years old,
there's now 100 children
who'd been identified with that problem.
The typical American office worker now focuses
on any one task for only three minutes.
And I started thinking well, what's happened to us, right?
What's happening to our attention?
Because I thought right at the start of this I thought...
I just thought the problem
was that I didn't have enough willpower.
I thought I wasn't strong enough.
And I also thought the problem was that someone
invented the smartphone, right?
Those were basically the two stories I had in my head.
But when I began to research this I ended up
going all over the world.
From Moscow to Miami to Melbourne,
to interview the leading experts on attention
and focus in the world.
I interviewed over 200 of them.
And what I learned is that actually from them
and from digging really deeply into their research
over three years.
What I learned from them is that there's actually
scientific evidence for 12 factors
that can make your attention better or can make it worse.
And loads of the factors that can make it worse
have been hugely supercharged in recent times.
So we are in a serious attention crisis.
But people need to understand if you're struggling to focus
and pay attention or if your kids are this isn't your fault,
this is happening to almost all of us.
Your attention didn't collapse,
your attention has been stolen from you by these big forces.
And together we can take on those forces.
Right, front and center is tech and tech addiction
and what's happening with our smartphones, et cetera.
But what was interesting about the book
is that you kind of...
You go into that, of course,
but there's also all of these other factors that you...
You have 12, right?
That are contributing to all of this.
I think it's fair to say and correct me if I'm wrong
that the book on some level
is sort of a graduate course extrapolation
on the documentary, The Social Dilemma.
You interview many of the same people,
most notably Tristan Harris and Jaron Lanier,
who've feature in that documentary.
And you kind of highlight the issues
that that documentary brought up.
But you go into them a little bit more deeply
and then you kind of venture beyond that to evaluate
these other risk factors or contributors
to this situation such as pollutants and stress,
and sleep deprivation, exhaustion and the like.
So I found it very interesting
and comprehensive in that regard.
Oh, thank you.
But I think if you...
For the listeners out there,
if you responded to that documentary
which we've talked about at length on this podcast
in the past 'cause I found it to be so profound.
This book really is kind of the next step in digging deeper
and exploring that subject matter.
Well, I think of it...
And I think you're totally right about The Social Dilemma
and those documentary makers
because it takes me so long to write my books.
They came along while I was doing interviews
with those guys.
And you had known Tristan before that, right?
You go way back with him.
I've been interviewing him for years now.
I think he's one of the great heroes of our time.
And such an important thinker,
and such a wonderful human being.
But the way I start to think about it,
I think you've framed it really right there, Rich.
The way I start to think about it is if you think about
some aspects of the tech we're currently using, no...
By no means all of them.
If you think of those as like a virus, right?
They came along and they would've been powerful at any time,
but they came along at a moment when immune system
was already down, when we were already doing
lots of things that were profoundly damaging our ability
to focus and pay attention.
So one of the reasons we've got such a serious
attention crisis is we've got the combination
of technology that is designed to hack and invade
our attention combined with all these factors
that are in different ways undermining
our ability to pay attention.
So I give you that can sound a bit fancy or weird,
so I'll give you a very obvious example.
We sleep 20% less than we did a century ago.
Children sleep 85 minutes less than they did 100 years ago.
And I interviewed the leading sleep experts
in the world and they explain to me,
look, the scientific evidence is overwhelming.
If you wanna be able to focus and pay attention
you've gotta get a really good night's sleep.
You've actually ideally gotta get eight hours sleep a night.
40% of Americans are chronically sleep deprived,
they're getting less than seven hours a night.
In fact, only 15% of us currently wake up feeling refreshed.
And obviously, I delved a lot into the science of this.
But there was one finding in particular
that really drove it home for me.
There's an amazing guy called Dr. Charles Czeisler,
who's at Harvard Medical School.
He's arguably the leading sleep expert in the world.
He's advised everyone from the Boston Red Sox
to the U S Secret Service.
He discovered if you are awake for 19 hours,
which doesn't feel like very much when I say it.
Your attention deteriorates
as much as if you had got legally drunk.
But he did this experiment, it's very simple.
He's the first person to combine these technologies
when studying sleep.
There's a technology that can scan your eyes
to see what you're looking at,
and there's a technology that we all know about
that can scan your brain.
And so we put them together he gets tired of people,
and they're not even that tired into this machine
and he tracks them.
What they're looking at and what's happening
in their brains.
And what he discovered is kind of mind blowing.
You can be...
As awake as you and I appear to be,
you can be looking around you, you can be talking,
but whole parts of your brain kind of gone to sleep.
It's called local sleep cause it's local
to one of the brain.
So when we say I'm half asleep,
it turns out that's not a metaphor, right?
A lot of us are literally half asleep a lot of the time.
And there's a lot of reasons why this is so important
for our attention.
One is as Professor Roxanne Prichard,
University of Minneapolis,
explain to me is that when you're sleeping
your brain is repairing, it's healing itself.
Throughout the day when you're awake
metabolic waste builds up in your brain, right?
She calls it brain cell poop.
And when you're sleeping a watery fluid
rinses through your brain and it carries
this brain cell poop out of your brain
down into your liver and eventually out of your body.
If you don't sleep your brain doesn't clean out
that metabolic waste.
You know that feeling when you're almost hung...
You feel almost hung over or clogged up when you are tired?
Well, that's 'cause your brain is literally clogged up.
So you can see that's one example, right?
Of how we sleep much less.
Think about how if you have a night where you don't sleep,
the next day you're much more likely to be mindlessly
scrolling through Tik Tok than a night where you
had a really good night's sleep.
So you can see that's one of many factors
that are undermining our ability to focus.
And then that combines with technologies
that are currently designed...
The technology doesn't have to work this way.
But the technologies that are currently designed
to hack and invade our attention as much as possible.
You can see how that's such a kind of toxic combination.
And I think for people who want to think about this,
it's worth thinking about why that's such
a toxic combination.
And I would just say to anyone watching or listening,
think about anything you've ever achieved in your life
that you're proud of.
Whether it's starting a business,
being a good parent, learning to play the guitar.
Whatever that thing you're proud of is,
that thing required a lot of sustained focus and attention.
And the evidence shows that when attention breaks down
your ability to achieve your goals breaks down,
your ability to solve your problems breaks down.
That's why this is such a deep problem.
When you have a long period when you can't pay attention
I feel like it's almost like you can...
You become almost like a stump of yourself, right?
You can sense what you might have been
if you've been able to apply yourself
but you feel like you can't get there.
This is why I think deep...
We really need to think deeply about
what's happened to our attention and we need to build
the scientific solutions which I saw all over the world
from France to New Zealand for how we get it back.
Well, positive progress requires
some level of sustained attention by bright people
focused on those problems, right?
And if there's a degradation of that,
that doesn't bode well for the future of humankind
and society, right?
(Johann laughs)
So that's why I really do think it is existential crisis.
I think that's a really good way you just put that.
It makes me think about this guy called Dr. James Williams,
who worked...
Was a senior figure at Google for many years,
was horrified by what they were doing
to our attention, quit.
And his become I would argue the leading
philosopher of attention in the world right now.
I interviewed him in Moscow in Russia,
and he lives there 'cause his wife works there
for the World Health Organization.
And he said to me...
He gave me a metaphor that really stayed with me.
He said, "Imagine you're driving somewhere,
you gotta do something.
And someone just throws an enormous bucket of mud
over your windshield.
Doesn't matter what you've gotta do when you get
to your destination,
the first thing you've gotta do is clean your windshield.
Because you can't get any anywhere
if you don't clean the windshield."
And I think that's a good metaphor for the attention crisis.
Doesn't matter what you wanna do in your life,
if you can't pay attention you won't be able to do it.
So the first thing we need to do is deal with the deep
underlying factors that are damaging our attention
in the way we eat, in the technology we use,
in the hours we work, in the polluted air we breathe,
there's all these factors but this to me
is the first of the crisis.
'Cause it's not that there aren't bigger crises in the world
but if we don't deal with this one
we can't get to any of the bigger crises
either in our personal lives or in a bigger societal sense.
Yeah, and both the problems and the solutions
can be bifurcated into two categories,
the systemic and the individualistic, right?
There are certain things that we can do
to kind of rebut this and there are also systemic problems
that need to be addressed
and we can talk about all of those.
But I wanna kind of hearken back
to the Provincetown experience
(Johann laughs)
because it's fresh in my mind
because I just got back from a month sabbatical.
I was in Hawaii.
And unlike you I didn't leave my phone on the mainland
but I did promise myself that I would restrict
my access to the phone and my time spent on it.
Like I really needed to get away from work.
And I do this every year and it's an opportunity
to kind of just refresh myself and relax
and return with a renewed enthusiasm for what I do
'cause I've tiptoed up to burnout a couple times.
And when you're kind of endeavoring to have
a truncated relationship with devices it becomes very...
You're very aware and present with the allure
and the pull of it.
And I probably...
I said this the other day
but like I would give myself a B minus.
I only checked email like once every two days.
And I have to FaceTime with my kids
and all that kind of stuff
so I wasn't gonna get rid of the phone.
But there were plenty of times where I found myself
just scrolling for no reason.
And I'm like, "What are you doing?
You're here to not do that.
You're here to have an analog experience and yet I can't."
(chuckles)
I would do it and there is a sense of powerlessness over it
which goes to both the individualistic relationships
that we have with these devices but also the great forces
and systemic powers that are behind the scenes
with these things that make them so irresistible.
How did you feel different
when you were able to go longer without it?
Well, of course better.
Yeah, fantastic and then...
But then you like...
In a moment you resort to it (laughs)
and you're doing it again.
And then you find yourself getting aggravated
and then I'm like, "What are you...
And then there's a vicious cycle
'cause then I'm beating myself up for doing the thing
that I said that I wasn't going to do.
This is exactly the dilemma that I had right
at the start of working on the book
that led me to Provincetown
and this period of three months completely off the internet.
'Cause I had this moment with my godson who I call Adam
in the book that when I realized something was really wrong.
So when he was nine he developed this brief
but freakishly intense obsession with Elvis
and it was particularly cute cause he didn't know that
Elvis had become this kind of cheesy cliche.
So he did it with like really heart catching sincerity
he would do this Elvis impersonation.
And when I used to tuck him in,
he kept getting me to tell him the story of Elvis' life
again and again.
I tried to skip over the bit...
At the end where he dies on the toilet.
And one day he said to me very intensely,
he looked at me and said,
"Johann, will you take me to Graceland one day?"
And I was like, "Sure, I'll take you to Graceland one day."
And the way you and nine year olds,
knowing that next week it'll be Legoland or whatever.
And he said, "No, do you really promise
you'll take me to Graceland?"
I was like, "I Absolutely promise."
And I didn't think at that moment again for 10 years
until everything had gone wrong.
So he dropped out of school when he was 15
and by the time he was 19 he just spent literally
all his waking hours alternating between WhatsApp,
Snapchat, porn, YouTube.
And one day we were sitting on my sofa in my apartment
and I was...
I'd been trying to talk to him all day
and he's a lovely, intelligent person
and just nothing was getting any traction in his mind.
And to be honest with you, Rich
I wasn't that much better, right?
I was sitting there staring at my own devices mindlessly.
And I suddenly remembered this moment
all these years before and I said to him,
"Hey, let's go to Graceland."
And he couldn't even remember this moment, right?
He's like, "What you're talking about?"
And I said, "No, let's go to Graceland.
We've gotta break this numbing routine,
let's get out of here.
Let's go all over the south.
But you've gotta promise me one thing
which is that when we go you'll leave your phone
in the hotel."
And he said, "I absolutely promise I'll do that."
And what if it was two weeks later we took off
at New Orleans.
We traveled around two weeks later we got to Graceland.
Have you been to Graceland, Rich?
No.
Oh, I'm gonna take you one day.
So when you arrive at the gates-
(indistinct) is that a promise?
I promise 10 years from now-
(Johann and Rich laughing)
Yeah, 10 years.
There gonna be some broken (indistinct).
But I'm a 65 year old man.
Yeah, you gonna take me to Graceland.
(Johann laughs)
We'll do it.
And it's a funny thing cause even before COVID,
when you get to Graceland now there's no person
to show you around.
What happened is they hand you an iPad
and you put in earbuds and the iPad shows you around.
So it says, go left, go right, whatever.
And as you're walking around there's a representation
of the room that you're in on the iPad, right?
And it erase the history of it whatever.
So what happens is everyone just walks around Graceland
staring at their iPad or barely looking up, right?
And I'm walking around I'm feeling like more and more tense,
like trying to make eye contact to people who looking down.
And we got to the Jungle Room,
which was Elvis' favorite room in Graceland.
And there was a Canadian couple next to us
and the husband turned to his wife and said,
"Honey, this is amazing.
Look, if you swipe left, you can see the Jungle Room
to the left and if you swipe right,
you can see the Jungle Room to the right.
And I laugh 'cause I thought he was kidding.
And I turn to looked at him and they're just swiping
back and forth and I leaned over and I said,
"But hey sir, there's an old fashion inform of swiping
you could do it's called turning your head
'cause look we're actually in the Jungle Room, right?
You don't have to look at it on your screen.
We're actually there."
And they backed away clearly thinking I was insane.
And I turned to my godson to laugh about it
and he was in the corner of the room just flicking
through Snapchat 'cause he could not stop
from the minute we land he couldn't stop.
And I went up to him and I just said,
"Look, I know you are afraid of missing out
but this is guaranteeing that you are miss out.
You're not showing up to your own life.
You're not pre isn't your own existence, right?
This is no way to live."
And he stormed off and I wondered around Memphis
on my own that day.
And I found him that night in the Heartbreak Hotel
where we were staying across the street
and he was sitting by the guitar (indistinct) swimming pool.
And I went out to him and I apologized for getting angry
and he was just scrolling and scrolling and didn't look up
but he said, "I know something's really wrong
but I dunno what it is."
And that's when I thought
okay, I need to investigate this.
And when I came back from Memphis,
I was just so tired of being wired.
I was disgusted by what I saw happening to me,
to so many people around me.
And at that time I still was stuck in those two stories
that this was a failure of willpower
and someone invented the smartphone.
I later learned there's a much more interesting
and complex story happening to all of us.
So I thought okay those are the two problems
I've got a solution here.
I was lucky the film writes to one of my books
had just been sold.
It was made into a film called
The United States Vs. Billie Holiday
And I just thought I'm done,
I'm gonna take this money and I'm gonna go away
for three months and I'm gonna be completely offline.
So I rented a little sliver of a beach house
in Provincetown in Cape Cod.
And I left my phone and my laptop in Boston, right?
My smartphone and I took a laptop...
My friend (indistinct) gave me his broken old laptop
that can't get online.
And yeah and those three months taught me
just a huge amount.
Right, so during that period of time
I'm sure you didn't really talk about this in the book
but I would suspect for at least...
I don't know, seven to 10 days there had to be
kind of a detoxification like weaning off
like kind of you're grab...
Grabbing for the phone that's not there
or just feeling antsy because you can't get that
immediate dopamine fixed that the phone will always provide?
It is funny that was the first five or six days
were just like a haze of decompression
I almost felt stoned, right?
Like just...
I felt a tremendous likeness and sense of relief
but I was exhausted by that.
I had been working unbelievably hard in the run up to it
that might have just been just being on a break, right?
And then but I kept having these...
It was a physical response where I would...
Exactly what you describe I pat my pocket I'm feeling panic
you think shit where am I put my phone?
You're like, oh yeah, you don't have it.
I had a...
I'd bought a phone it's called the Jitterbug.
It's the only phone you can buy
in the United States now that won't...
It has no internet capacity.
(Rich laughs)
It's designed for extremely old people as enormous buttons.
And it has an emergency button
so that if you fall over
it will call the nearest hospital.
So I thought all right, it's win-win.
And it's funny I would open that phone in those seven days
and just sort of stab at the buttons.
Couldn't do any...
The phone literally does nothing.
And it reminded me of when I was a kid I saw maybe
some David Attenborough wildlife documentary
of a mother penguin whose baby has died.
And she just keeps nudging it to try to get it
to do something.
And I kept the of that and then I had a real crash,
a terrible crash.
It was interesting.
I remember I was walking down the beach in Provincetown
behind the West End of Provincetown for people who know it.
And I was seeing what I'd seen in Memphis, right?
People just...
Provincetown is one of the most beautiful places
in the world.
And people were just looking at their phones.
People with kids weren't even looking at their kids
it was driving me insane.
It would dri...
Normally it would drive me insane
but this time instead of saying to them,
oh, you're not present in your lives.
You're not...
I wanted to go up to them and go gimme that phone.
I want it, right?
(chuckles)
I wanted to...
And it was interesting this tremendous hunger
'cause I realized for 15 years prior to that
throughout the day I had been completely climatized
to receiving the kind of thin insistent signals
we get from the web which are designed as rewards
to keep us coming back.
Retweets, hearts, likes, we all know how they work.
And when they were gone...
This will bit sound a bit pretentious,
it is a bit pretentious.
But Simone de Beauvoir,
the great French philosopher said that
when she became an atheist,
it was like the world had gone silent.
And that's how I felt.
I felt like the world had gone silent, right?
Like these signals I was so used to were gone
and no normal social interaction
even though I was meeting amazing people
they don't flood you with hearts the minute you meet them
that would be a very weird social interaction, right?
And that was when I realized a big part of this,
if you just extricate yourself in that that a vacuum,
you need to then fill that vacuum.
And that was when I started to read a lot more
and later interview the leading scientist
in the world on flow states.
And that was how I kind of got out of it
we can talk about that a bit if you like.
Yeah, I mean, there's a lot to unpack there
but I think kind of the lesson that I think is powerful
for anybody who's listening to this is
over that course of three months through
that detachment process you were able
to kind of restore your sleep
like sleeping better than ever,
repair your ability to sit down and work on a book
and focus, be tuned into the news by reading
a newspaper every day and then that being that
for the rest of the day.
(Johann chuckles)
Connect with friends, be present in your life.
And you explain this time of waking up and not feeling
like you needed to drink coffee and feeling just awake
in a way that you hadn't since you were a young boy.
And a lot of this is about returning
to a more natural state of man, right?
We live in the modern world we're not gonna go live in caves
or anything like that and it's unrealistic
that we're gonna be luddites.
But to the extent that we can exert some control
over these tectonic forces that are driving us
to this exhausted state there are things that we can do.
And your experience as an example of how
these natural states that have alluded us can be restored.
Yeah, yes, so you put it really well.
It was one of the things that amazed me...
'Cause I thought I was nearly 40 at the time.
I thought oh, maybe what's happening
is I've just got older, right?
And maybe a brain just gets deters.
My attention went back to being as good as it had been
when I was 17.
I could sit and read a book for eight hours a day
and focus deeply.
And I later realized that wasn't just about
the tech withdrawal that was many things,
many changes that happened.
I completely changed the way I ate, these...
None of these things were conscious at the time
it was when I later interviewed the scientists
who've researched this sort of thing
that I realized how much those changes have weighed on me.
My sleep, he mentioned lots of factors.
But I think you're right there's two ways
we have to respond to this crisis or two kinds of way
we've gotta respond to this crisis.
I think of them as defense and offense, right?
We've gotta defend ourselves and our children
as much as possible from these forces
that are pouring acid on our attention.
And I talk a lot...
Give dozens of examples in the book about things we can do.
But I wanna be honest with people about this
that will hugely help.
I'm passionately in favor of those things.
I try to do all of them myself
but that will only get you so far.
'Cause at the moment it's like someone
is pouring itching powder over us all the time
and then leaning forward and going,
hey buddy, you might wanna learn how to meditate
then you wouldn't scratch so much.
And you wanna apply going well,
screw you I'll learn to meditate.
(Rich chuckles)
You stop pouring itching powder on me.
Which is why we've gotta have an element of offense,
we've gotta take on the forces that are doing this to us.
Now that can sound very fancy and grand.
I talk about lots of practical ways that can be done
and ways it has already been done in many parts of the world
and ways it was done in the past in the United States.
But you you're right that we've gotta get...
When you say this about the way we live
you're absolutely right.
Even I was doing that I thought
well, this is not sustainable.
And I remember...
So of course, what I was asking was
well, how can we integrate some of these insights
into our normal lives?
And I remember the last day I was in Provincetown
going to what's it called?
Where the lighthouse is there's a spot where you can
look back over the whole of Provincetown.
I hadn't left Provincetown the whole three months.
I hadn't been in a moving vehicle for three months.
So I could see the kind of whole landscape
of where I had been (clears throat)
and remember thinking,
well, I'm never gonna go back to living how I lived before.
Why would I do that?
This has been amazing, right?
The joys of deep thought of reflection, of mind wandering,
of the joys of being present in your life,
they're so profound.
Why would I go back?
And I got the boat back to Boston,
I got the ferry back to Boston.
I got horribly sick on the journey.
My friend (indistinct) gave me back my laptop and my phone.
And within a month I'd say I was 80% back where I've been.
Yeah, that was the...
(chuckles)
How long did it take before you were just completely
where you were before?
Well, I only really began to understand why
when I went to interview Dr. Williams.
The attention philosopher who I mentioned
who had been at the heart of Google.
I remember James saying to me,
"The mistake you've made, Johann
is it's like thinking the solution to air pollution
is for you personally to wear a gas mask."
I'm not against gas masks.
If I lived in Beijing I'd wear a gas mask,
but gas masks aren't the solution to air pollution, right?
In an environment that is deeply invading our attention.
I mean, Professor Joel Nigg,
one of the leading experts on children's attention problems
in the world.
And as you know a big part of the book is about
what's happening to our kids.
Professor Nigg said to me that we need to ask if we're now
living in what he called
an attentional pathogenic environment.
An environment that is undermining the ability of most of us
to pay attention.
And if that's the case, (clears throat)
and I think the evidence is pretty clear it is.
Then we have to think about how together can we change
our environment in order to deal with those factors
that are so invading our focus and attention.
And there are lots of practical ways we can do that.
Sorry to interrupt the flow
we'll be right back with more awesome.
But I wanna snag a moment to talk to you about
the importance of nutrition.
The thing is most people I know actually already know
how to eat better and aspire to incorporate
more whole plants, more fruits, vegetables, seeds, beans,
and legumes into their daily routine.
Sadly, however, without the kitchen tools and support
very few end up sticking with it.
So because adopting a plant-based diet transformed my life
so profoundly.
And because I want everybody to experience
some version of what I've experienced
we decided to tackle and solve this very common problem.
The solution we've devised I'm proud to say
is the Plantpower Meal Planner are affordable all in one
digital platform that sets you up for nutrition excellence
by providing access to thousands of highly customizable,
super delicious and easy to prepare plant-based recipes.
Everything integrates with automatic grocery delivery
and you get access to our amazing team
of nutrition coaches seven days a week
and many other features.
To learn more and to sign up visit meals.richroll.com.
And right now for a limited time we're offering $10 off
in annual membership when you use the promo code
RRHEALTH at checkout.
This is life changing stuff people for just $1.70 a week,
literally the price of a cup of coffee.
Again, that's meals.richroll.com,
promo code RRHEALTH for $10 off in annual membership.
All right, let's get back to the show.
It feels as if there's so much working against us
so in terms of the individualistic changes that we can make
and you talk about like you can get these lock boxes
for your phone and you can use the Freedom app
and you can set intentions ahead of time
about what your habits are going to be.
I feel like those are all great
and I have some of those myself that I deploy.
But ultimately, that feels like it's only gonna get you
like 15% there.
That's-
I'm not talking about the sleep
and the other stuff is-
(indistinct chatter)
You have more agency over that
because the systemic forces are so powerful.
And rebutting those systemic forces,
and I'm talking specifically about tech
is really going to require a populist movement
in order to change.
And you talk about other movements in the past
and in this call to action that we do have
more power than we think we have in terms of making change.
Let's look at example from our lifetimes
of the collective action that profoundly improved attention.
So you'll remember, Rich, I can just from remember it.
It used to be totally normal that people use
leaded gasoline in their cars.
It was the standard form of gasoline.
And a bit before our time it was completely normal
that people use leaded paint in their homes.
And it was discovered that exposure to lead
profoundly damages people's brains and in particular,
absolutely ruins children's ability to focus
and pay attention.
So what happened a group of ordinary moms
that was mostly moms learned this evidence,
could see it happening to their kids,
and banded together and said, "Why are we allowing this?
Why are we allowing a for-profit industry
to screw up our abilities,
our children's ability to pay attention?"
And it's really important to notice what they didn't say.
They didn't say ban all gasoline.
They didn't say ban all paint.
They said ban the lead in the paint and in the gasoline.
And it took a while,
they had to fight for years but they succeeded, right?
There is no leaded gasoline in this country anymore.
There's no leaded paint.
There's still some leaded pipes but other than that
which we've gotta get rid of.
And that was originally part of the
Build Back Better program that sadly got taken out.
So and that reduction in exposure to lead,
the CDC, the Centers for Disease Control said
it has "Caused an improvement...
An average improvement of three to five IQ points
in American children per child."
So you can see that you identify something
that's damaging attention, we ban together,
we fight for it,
We get it out of the environment.
There are lots of equivalent to the lead
and the lead paint
that we're talking about now.
So I'll give one-
The fluorocarbons example and deodorants,
and things like...
I mean, the suffragette movement,
Mothers Against Drunk Driving,
there's tons of examples similar to that.
But we are all the beneficiaries of people in the past
who identify something that was wrong.
People said, "Oh, this is hopeless will never fix it."
But they banded together, they fought for it,
and they put it right.
And you know, Dr. Williams who I'm quoting a lot
in this interview he's a great person said to me,
thinking about the tech example he said,
"Look, the axe existed for 1.4 million years
before anyone even thought to put a handle on it."
The entire internet has existed for less than
10,000 days, right?
We can fix these things,
these factors that are doing this to us are quite recent.
A lot of them not all of them but most of them
are quite recent, they're relatively new,
they are created by humans.
We're humans we can disinvent or deal with those factors
that are doing this to us.
There are equivalents to the lead in the lead paint,
just like we don't wanna get rid of gasoline,
and we don't wanna get rid of paint.
We don't wanna get rid of tech,
tech is a great thing.
We're not gonna all convert and join the Amish,
nor should we.
No disrespect to any Amish viewers watching in
and watching now.
But we can deal with the specific factors
that are doing this to us.
So I'll give you an example,
there's lots of individual things we can do
as we've talked about and I'm sure we'll get to lots more.
But let's look at a social example that I think everyone
just when they hear it gets how?
How this improves attention?
In France in 2018,
they're having a big crisis of what they called low burnout,
which I don't think I need to translate.
And the French government under pressure
from labor unions open an investigation to figure out
what the hell is going on?
Why is everyone getting burned out?
And one of the things they discovered
is that 35% of French people felt they could never
stop checking their phone or their email.
Because their boss could message them
at any time of the day or night
and if they didn't answer they could be in trouble.
So you can see how that's a very recent thing.
I mean, when we were kids the only people who were on call
were doctors and even doctors weren't on call
all the time, right?
So we've gone from almost nobody being on call,
maybe the president was on call 24 hours a day
to almost half the economy being on call all the time.
You can see how that means.
I can give those people all the lovely self-help
lectures about the benefits of unplugging,
of getting more sleep.
But they're gonna say, screw you, I can't do that.
And they're entirely right in the current configuration
we've got they can't.
This is why the French government introduced something
very simple legal reform.
It's called the right to disconnect.
It gives every French worker two rights.
First right is your work hours have to be laid out
in your work contract.
And second part is you have a legal right
to not check your email or answer your phone
when your work hours are over,
unless they are formally paying you over time, right?
Now you can see how that is called the right to disconnect.
You can see how giving people the right to disconnect
is a collective change that we've gotta fight for together
that frees people up to make a lot of the individual changes
they wanna make.
Now there's lots of changes like that
where the collective change enables people
to make the individual change.
Whether it's...
Which of course, not say there aren't individual things
we can do at the moment as well there absolutely are.
Does that ring true to you, Rich?
Yeah, of course.
It's a very tactile low hanging fruit solution
that makes a lot of sense
and feels like is appropriate because it's true.
We are all kind of like available all the time
and I think that that is beyond draining
and creates undue pressures on us that elevate
our cortisol and our stress levels and comparability
to sleep and have all these downstream implications.
I think the issue with kind of to go back
to your lead and gasoline example.
The kind of qualitative difference with tech is that
this is so much more complex than removing an ingredient
from a consumer product.
The speed at which technology continues to advance
and AI continues to mature has a rapidity to it
that so far outpaces government's ability
to even understand it let alone regulate it.
And there are so few people that truly understand it
which is why people like Tristan are so important
and his foundation.
So even just getting a grip
on what exactly is happening is challenging,
let alone understanding it sufficiently enough
to be able to figure out what a remedy would be.
And you have some.
I mean, I wanna talk about kind of the business plan pivots
'cause I think that's interesting.
I Think you're right about getting a handle
we have to understand some of the ways in which
what we're doing now is harming our attention.
So let's look at an example I think will ring true
to everyone listening, right?
So I went to interview Professor Earl Miller at MIT,
he's one of the leading neuroscientists in the world.
And he said to me, "There's one thing about the human brain
you've gotta understand more than anything else.
You can only consciously think about one or two things
at a time that's it."
This is a fundamental limitation of the human brain.
The human brain has not significantly changed
in the last 40,000 years.
It ain't gonna change on any time scale we gonna see.
You can only think about one or two things at a time.
But what's happened is we've fallen as a culture
for a mass delusion.
The average teenager now believes they can follow
six or seven forms of media at the same time.
So what happens is...
And this has been studied a huge amount.
Scientists get people into labs and they get them to think
they're doing more than one thing at a time.
And what they discover every time is the same thing.
You're not doing more than one thing at a time,
you're very rapidly juggling between the tasks.
And your consciousness kind of papers over it
so you don't...
You feel like you're doing the things
at the same time but you're not.
And what they find is when you try and do
more than one thing at a time,
something called the switch cost effect kicks in.
Everyone should know this term, the switch cost effect
'cause it's harming your life.
The switch cost effect shows,
when you try and do more than one thing at a time
you will do all the things
you're trying to do much less competently.
You'll make more mistakes,
you'll remember less of what you do,
you'll be less creative.
And this feels like a small effect when you hear about it.
You (indistinct), "Yeah, okay, I get it."
But how big can that be?
The effect...
It shocked me when I learned about it.
The effect is enormous.
I'll give you two examples of just small studies
backed by much wider body of evidence that have found this.
Hewlett-Packard, the printer company got a scientist
into study their workforce
and they split their workers into two groups.
And the first group was told, "Just get on with your task,
whatever it is and you're not gonna be interrupted."
And the second group was told, "Get on with your task,
but you're gonna have to answer
a fairly heavy amount of email and phone calls."
So pretty much how most of us live our lives.
And then at the end of it they tested the IQ of both groups.
The group that had not been interrupted scored on average
10 IQ points higher than the group
that have been interrupted.
To give you a sense of how big an effect that is now.
If you get stoned your IQ goes down in the short term
by five points.
So being chronically distracted is twice as bad for your IQ,
your intelligence in the short term
as getting stoned, right?
That's a big effect.
Or look at another example,
Professor Larry Rosen discovered if you receive
eight text messages an hour which doesn't sound like
very much to me.
That lowers your brain power for the main thing
you're trying to focus on by 30%.
These are huge effects.
I would argue with most of us are losing about 30%.
Yeah.
Most of the time.
This is why professor Miller said to me,
"We are living in a perfect storm
of cognitive degradation at the moment
as a result of constant distraction."
And there's kind of two levels of which
we can respond to this.
Like we said, there's defense.
So you mentioned I own something called a kSafe, right?
I should totally be paying...
Being paid commission by these guys like you recommend it.
kSafe is a plastic safe,
you take off the lid you put in your phone,
you put on the lid and...
Do you have one, Rich?
No, but I know what it...
I know it exactly...
I know what it is.
Okay this is-
I do use Freedom though.
Yeah, so you turn the thing the dial at the top
and it will lock away your phone for anything
between five minutes and a whole day.
I will not sit down and watch a movie with my partner
unless we both imprison our phones.
If anyone comes around for dinner,
I will insist they imprison their phone.
I use that lockbox for four hours a day
otherwise I would never been able to write
my book style off focus, right?
So and there's loads of things like that we can do
in terms of changing what we eat,
and a whole range of other things.
But you are right,
and this is where Tristan...
The layer that Tristan and other people who've been
at the heart of Silicon Valley and are now trying
to expose this are so important.
At the moment we are using technologies
that are extraordinarily sophisticated in figuring out
how to get us to pick up our phone as often as possible
and scroll as long as possible.
And I can talk more about that if you like
and I know you have thoughts on this as well, Rich?
And saying you cover a lot on the podcast.
But we can deal with that, right?
There's absolutely practical ways we can deal with that,
I can talk about if you like.
I'm conscious of giving long answers.
Yeah, no, I definitely wanna get into that.
But just in response to what you just said,
it kind of dovetails into a conversation
around flow as well.
Which is the antithesis of this distracted state
of multitasking and as a parent of teenagers I can tell you.
(Johann laughs)
It's like their kind of like default M.O.
is to lay on their bed in their room
and there's an iPad, there's a laptop and there's a phone,
and there's generally a FaceTime happening
with one of their friends where...
I don't know if you know this
but like one thing teens do is
they just have the FaceTime on in the background
especially during the pandemic.
So they feel like they're with their friend
and they're not even really interacting that much.
It's just comforting to know like your friend
is laying on their bed in their house.
And every once in a while you can check in.
One of the is doing home work,
the other ones watching The Office,
and maybe playing a video.
There's like...
All these inputs are happening
while the scrolling of course, and all of that.
So I've witnessed firsthand this dynamic
and it's hugely problematic because it is on some level
implicitly informing them that they can do
all of these things well or fine at the same time
which is an illusion.
And anybody who's tried to sit down and execute
on a project particularly creative people.
I mean, the easiest example is writing a book.
If you're in that state and you're focused
and you are experiencing a certain level of flow.
In that process you're doing a painting or a sculpture,
or writing a song or whatever it is.
And you get interrupted that switch cost effect
is very real.
Like you've experienced that because it's not like,
oh, I got interrupted.
Even if it's someone knocks on your door
and says, hey, can you...
Don't forget to go to the grocery store or whatever.
The amount of time it takes to get back
into that flow state,
you can't just switch it on and off.
Like you...
I mean, it's like a half an hour before you feel
like you can tap into where you were
before that seemingly innocuous interruption.
Yeah, it's so important, Rich.
And what you're saying is so right.
And for people who dunno about flow states,
everyone listening will have experienced a flow state
in your life, in their lives.
So a flow state is when you're doing something
and you really get into it.
You get into the zone and your sense of time falls away,
your sense of ego falls away and you are just in it.
The way one rock climber put it is,
"When you're in flow,
you feel like you are the rock you're climbing."
And flow is really important for the attention debate
'cause flow is simultaneously the deepest
form of attention we can provide.
When you're in a flow state your attention is fully on it
and once you get into it,
it's the easiest form of attention to provide, right?
When you're in a flow state it's not like memorizing facts
for an exam.
It's like, oh, okay what is that?
What's that?
It's like a gusher of attention inside all of us.
So obviously, one thing I wanted to understand is
okay, if it's a gusher of attention inside all of us
where do we drill?
How do we get it?
So I went to interview Professor Mihaly Csikszentmihalyi,
you have no idea how long it took me to learn how
to say that.
Who was the man who coined the phrase
flow states in the 1960s.
A completely...
One of the most important psychologists
of the last half century I would argue.
And he spent 50 years studying flow states.
Sadly, I think I did the last interview he ever did
'cause he died shortly afterwards.
And Professor Csikszentmihalyi said to me
many important things about flow.
But for me I think there are three be really useful
for your listeners and your viewers
if they wanna maximize their chances of getting into flow.
So there's three things you can do.
I mean, there's lots but I would say these are the three
most important.
The first is you've got to choose one goal and filter out
everything else you're trying to do, right?
If you're trying to do more than one thing at a time
you won't get into to flow.
So you've got to narrow your focus.
I wanna paint this canvas.
I wanna climb this rock.
I wanna write this chapter.
You gotta do one thing.
The second thing is the goal you choose
has got to be meaningful to you, right?
So for you it might be painting a canvas,
for me I can't paint for shit, right?
I would normally get to flow on that.
For you it might be going for a run.
The only time I ever went for a run is when I once thought
KFC was gonna close and I got there
and it was another hour to go.
Waste of time that was.
So and yeah so different people will have different things
that get them into flow.
If you're trying to focus on something
that is not meaningful to you,
your attention will just slip and slide off it.
And the third is it will really help if you choose something
that is at the edge of your comfort zone,
at the edge of your ability.
So let's say you're a middle talent rock climber, right?
You don't wanna just climb over your garden wall.
That's not gonna get you into flow it's too easy.
Equally you don't wanna suddenly tomorrow
climb Mount Kilimanjaro it's gonna be too overwhelming.
You wanna choose a slightly higher and harder rock face
than the one you climbed last time.
So if you do these three things,
narrow down to one goal, make sure it's a meaningful goal,
choose one at the edge of your comfort zone,
you'll maximize your chances of getting that deep
gusher of attention.
But even as I say that, Rich,
you can see like you're saying how the environment
in which we live is militating.
Step one, killing it, right?
You've gotta do one thing.
If you're being constantly texting...
There was a study by Professor Michael Posner,
at the University of Oregon.
That found if you are interrupted it takes you on average
23 minutes to get back to the level of focus you had
before you were interrupted.
But many of us are never getting 23 minutes to spare, right?
You think about something as simple as
someone texts you and they're off
you didn't immediately reply
and they go, "But it would've only taken you two seconds?"
And one of the things I've been trying to educate people
in my life is saying,
"You think it will only take two seconds,
actually it'll take me two seconds plus the 23 minutes
it takes me to get back to the focus I had before."
If you and I were checking our texts now I'd be going...
While you were saying the really interesting things
you just said.
If I just glance at my text
it feels like such a small thing.
And then I'd have to focus on text
oh, my friend texted me and said that.
But what's Rich saying?
And that incurs the switch cost effect and it kills flow.
So this is, yeah.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which means you have to exercise a lot of diligence,
or to put it in the cases.
The way I do it is I sort of...
I'm like all right, I'm gonna work on this
for a certain period of time.
And then maybe I'll reward myself with
five minutes of checking messages to make sure the world
didn't explode in the meantime.
(Johann laughs)
But going into that understanding that even if that takes
five minutes it's not five minutes,
it's like 35 minutes of distracted time.
And am I willing to budget for that?
Or is that cause too severe and at odds with the goal
that I'm trying to achieve?
I think that's such a good way of putting it and you...
What's happening is a cumulative effect, right?
Where our attention is being degraded and degraded,
and degraded.
And I think it's worth thinking about
some of the other factors that people can do
in their own lives.
I think it will be really relevant to a lot of your views.
I mean, there's a big load of things we can do
about childhood now straight away.
I'd like to talk about them,
but let's look at food for a second, right?
So there's this really interesting movement
I know you know about called nutritional psychiatry.
A psychiatrists who are looking at how the way we eat
profoundly affects our brains function.
And there's three...
I interviewed loads of these nutritional psychiatrists
and other people who are experts on this.
And there's kind of three big ways...
There's actually more but there's three
in particularly big ways.
In which the way we eat at the moment
is damaging our ability specifically to focus
and pay attention.
So the first is very simple.
So let's imagine you have the standard
British or American breakfast that you grow up...
Most people in our countries have.
You eat in the morning sugary cereal and white bread,
or white bread with butter on it or whatever,
stuff like that.
What that does is that releases a huge amount of energy
really quickly into your brain.
It releases a lot of glucose and at first it feels great.
You're woke up for the day,
you suddenly feel like you're awake,
you're alert, you're in it.
But what happens is you get to your school desk,
or your kid gets to the school desk a couple of hours later,
and you experience a huge energy slump.
Because energy's released so quickly into your brain
that it just crashes.
And when your energy crashes
you experience something called brain fog.
Brain fog is when you can't really focus and pay attention,
you're just very, very distractible.
And you need another sugary carby treat
to get your brain back.
So the way we eat puts us on a roller coaster
of energy spikes and energy crashes throughout the day
that leaves us with these patches of brain fog
that profoundly damage our ability to focus
and pay attention.
The way Dale Pinnock,
one of Britain's leading nutritionist put it to me is,
"It's like we put rocket fuel into a mini."
You know those little British cards from the 70s.
It will go really fast for five minutes
and then it just stops.
So if you eat food like almost all our ancestors did
that releases energy steadily throughout the day,
you will be able to pay attention much better.
The second way in which the way is damaging our attention
is that for your brain to develop fully
you need certain nutrients and our diets are lacking
a lot of those nutrients.
An obvious one that most people
will have heard of are omega-3s.
And it turns out supplements just don't cut it, right?
Your body doesn't metabolize supplements
in the same way it metabolizes nutrients from real food.
The third factor to me is actually the most disturbing,
which is it's not just that our diets are lacking things
that we need for our brains to function.
Our diets also currently contain chemicals
that act on us like drugs.
So there's a study in Britain
in a city called Southampton in 2007,
where they got 297 kids and they split them into two groups.
And the first group was just given water to drink,
and the second group was given water laced with food dyes
that occur...
And the kind of food we get at the supermarket
all the time.
Popular candies that kind of thing.
And then they monitor the kids and the kids who were given
the food dies were significantly more likely
to become hyperactive, to manic, struggle with attention.
And interestingly in Britain and the European Union,
we banned most of those food dyes.
In the United States there's still on the market.
I'm sure that's one reason why there's a significant gap
between the United States and Europe when it comes to things
like attention problems in children.
So you can see how those factors...
Again, there's a kind of doubleness to that.
A lot of us can change the way we eat
but also the food industry needs to be challenged as well.
So more of us can make those changes.
Yeah, I mean, the food thing is something we've explored
at length on this podcast many, many times
and listeners are already kind of familiar
with that landscape.
But I think when you mention the dyes that brings up
this subject of environmental pollutants in beauty products,
and things we put on our skin and how we cleanse ourselves,
and how we clean our houses
and just what is in the air in general?
And what's crazy...
I did a podcast with a woman called Gregg Renfrew,
who is CEO and founder of a company called Beautycounter.
And they have created this incredibly robust,
successful company that produces beauty products for women
that are all chemical free.
And she came on and she's very well versed
in the kind of legislative regulatory landscape
regarding chemicals in consumer products.
And it's quite shocking and you talk about this
in the book as well.
The fact that the burden of proof is reversed.
Like we're allowed to put all of these crazy chemicals
in all these products and it's fine until proven harmful
when in fact it should be the reverse.
The burden proof should be on the corporation
to prove that they're safe before they find their way
into literally thousands of products.
And every year the number of like new chemicals
that find their way into these product...
I mean, I don't know what the numbers are but it's insane.
No, of all the causes that I write about
in Stolen Focus, all the 12 causes.
This is the one that most shocked me
and actually I think might be the biggest.
It might be 100 years from now when they look back
and they think, God, these people really struggle to focus.
Why?
This might be the single biggest reason
why they realize we struggled to focus.
Professor Barbara (indistinct),
who's one of the leading scientists in France.
She's won of the Legion of Honor,
their highest civilian honor said to me,
"It's not possible to have a normal brain today
because of the level of the pollutants
that we're exposed to."
And there's lots of these.
So there's another professor,
a brilliant professor called Barbara Maher in Britain
at the University of Lancaster who's done all this research.
Think about air pollution, right?
Very conscious of this air in Los Angeles.
So if you live in any major cities
particularly (indistinct),
you are breathing in air pollution that contains iron.
And when you breathe it in the iron goes straight
to your brain, right?
And there's nothing in human evolution that prepared us
for inhaling iron.
It's just no precedent for it.
And what happens when you breathe in iron
is it causes what Professor Maher calls,
a repeated chronic insult to the brain.
It causes brain inflammation.
There's research from all over the world now.
from places like Mexico City, Barcelona,
about the really harmful effects of (indistinct).
One study in Mexico City studied
kids who lived in polluted areas and kids who didn't,
compared them.
And the kids who lived in heavily polluted areas
had already had plaques and tangles like dementia patients
in their brains, right?
This is a huge effect.
And you're absolutely right about the way
we have to deal with this.
For almost all the other fact...
In fact, for literally all the other factors,
we've got those two levels of response.
There's the individual and the systemic,
defense and offense.
I'm afraid for this,
you can buy the cosmetics of the woman you're advocating
it sounds very good.
But for most of these factors
the solution has to be systemic.
Just like you couldn't individually protect yourself
from lead poisoning we had to ban the lead.
And you're right,
Professor Bruce Lanphear, he's a great guy at UBC,
University of British Columbia,
who I interviewed a lot in Horseshoe Bay.
He's doing fantastic campaigning on this.
People should go to his website, littlethingsmatter.
Think its littlethingsmatter.ca,
where they're doing fantastic work.
'Cause you are totally right.
At the moment, if I invent some new chemical
I can just release it.
And it's up to very poorly funded scientists to figure out
if it's harmful, right?
We don't do that with drugs.
If I invent a new drug I have to apply to the FDA,
the FDA checked me.
They don't do a great job they could do a better one.
But the FDA do lots of checks to make sure
that it's not gonna poison or harm people.
And then it gets released.
So what Professor Lanphear argues,
I think completely rightly is that we need to have
an equivalent to the FDA for industrial pollutants
and chemicals, right?
And we need to test the stuff
that's already being used
'cause there...
I mean, there's a chemical that's on most ring pull cans
that when monkeys are exposed to that profoundly damages
their working memory, their ability to do
the equivalent of monkey attention.
I mean, there's a loads of chemicals
that we are being exposed to that in tests on other animals,
non-human animals show profound harm.
Now we don't test these things on human children
for very good reasons and I'm in favor of that.
But you can see how we really need to deal with this.
This is urgent.
Yeah, it is crazy that it isn't properly regulated.
Crazy, well, and it's because we have a political system
that is owned by corrupt interests, right?
So we need to reclaim the political system
to democratize that.
Which is why I'm sympathetic to Bill Maher's dystopian.
(chuckles)
Pessimistic view on all of this because the powers that be,
these large corporations which include Facebook, Google,
the like carry so much influence
through lobbying, et cetera.
That it becomes difficult to imagine that things can change.
When I feel like that and sometimes I do,
maybe this will sound odd
I think a lot about my grandmothers.
My grandmothers were the age I am now in 1963,
I loved my grandmothers they were amazing women.
They both lived to be 91.
And in 1963, so one of them was a working class
Scottish woman living in what we would call
a housing project here in the United States.
And the other was a Swiss peasant woman living
in a wooden hut on the side of a mountain.
In 1963, neither of my grandmothers were allowed
to have bank accounts in their own name
'cause their married women.
It was legal for their husbands to rape them
as it was legal everywhere in the world for men
to rape their wives.
They had both left school when they were 13,
even though the men in their family went on longer
'cause no one gave a about girls learning anything.
My Swiss grandmother wasn't even allowed to vote, right?
And I think about their lives when they're the age I am,
there's not some distant history.
I knew the...
I loved them and knew them incredibly well.
And this is when they were the age I am now.
And I think about the gap from then to now,
I don't wanna underestimate how much further we've got to go
in achieving equality for women.
But I think about my Swiss grandmother loved to paint
and draw when she was a teenager.
They told her to shut up and get into the kitchen.
My niece, Erin is 17,
she never knew my grandmother sadly.
When she loved to paint and draw,
we didn't say shut up and get into the kitchen.
We started looking at art schools, right?
When people say, "Oh, the force harming our attention
are big and powerful."
I totally agree with you.
I've gotta tell you they're not a 10th as powerful
as men were in 1963.
Men controlled every country in the world,
every company in the world, every police force.
And they had ever since those things
had been invented, right?
Apart from a few hereditary queens every now and then.
And the women of that generation did not just say,
oh, we're fucked then how are we ever gonna win this?
They started where they stood.
They fought every level in every office,
every home, at national levels.
And again, I don't wanna underestimate how further
we gotta go,
but what a staggering transformation now.
Even crazy sexist wouldn't suggest that my niece
it should be legal to rape her,
or that she shouldn't be allowed to have a bank account,
or she shouldn't be allowed to vote.
I mean, even crazy incel...
Maybe the craziest incel says that.
But you'd have to go completely outside
the spectrum of normal discussion, right?
That happened in the space of a very short period
of time historically, right?
So absolutely we can deal with these things.
And I argue in the book that just like we needed a need,
our feminist movement for women to reclaim their bodies
and their lives, we need an attention movement
to reclaim our minds, right?
We need to do lots of things as individuals,
but we also need to realize this is being done to us.
It is being done by really powerful forces
and we need to change the nature of our demand, right?
'Cause at the moment we're just blaming ourselves.
Most people just blame themselves
for their attention problems or ask for these
tiny little tweaks.
And I'm in favor of all the tweaks people ask for.
But I think we need to realize we are not medieval peasants
begging at the court of king Zuckerberg
for a few little crumbs of attention from his table, right?
We are the free citizens of democracies, we have dignity.
We own our own minds and we can take them back
if we want to.
(siren wailing)
(upbeat music)
(indistinct chatter)
So let's talk about what those systemic changes
would look like in the case of tech?
You talk about these business plan modifications.
Right now these platforms are driven by an ad revenue model.
So all the incentives are misaligned to capture
and monopolize your attention,
to collect as much data as possible, as humanly feasible,
as AI feasible as they can to create this avatar
of who you are so they can sell that information
to advertisers to sell you products.
And as a result of that we're captured by these devices
and then kind of sold to the highest bid.
So untangling that knot would require dismantling
that entire business model of it being driven by ad revenue
and creating some different version.
Whether it's a subscription model or whether these things
that have become such gigantic (indistinct)
should now be qualified as public utilities.
I think you've put that really well, Rich.
So this took me a long time to get my head around.
So I went to Silicon Valley and I interviewed lots of people
who had been at the heart of this machinery.
And I remember Tristan the moment with Tristan
when we were walking in San Francisco one day,
remember him telling me something that really haunted me.
So for people who don't know
Tristan worked at the heart of-
Right, we keep mentioning his name
but I keep thinking in the back of my mind
I'm not sure we've actually explained who he is
for people that don't know.
So Tristan Harris worked at the heart of Google
for many years.
And initially he worked on the Gmail team,
and when they were developing Gmail.
And one of the things they were particularly keen on doing
early in Gmail was getting people to use Gmail
more often, right?
Get them to pick it up more often.
I'll explain why in a little while.
One day sitting in the Googleplex,
and one of his colleagues said, "I've got an idea.
Why don't we make it so that whenever people get an email
their phone vibrates a little bit."
And (indistinct) around and said, "Oh, that's a good idea.
Let's do that."
A few days later they switched it on.
A week later Tristan was walking around
San Francisco himself and he starts hearing
these vibrations everywhere like a kind of bird song.
And he realizes, oh, we did that.
He realized that was happening all over the world.
He calculated a little while later that that decision
his colleague made so casually
was causing 10 billion interruptions in the world
to people's day every day.
Think about the switch cost effect.
Think about what that's doing to people's attention, right?
And he becomes more and more uncomfortable.
And he initially spoke out within Google.
He believed he could persuade people within Google.
He worked unbelievably hard at that.
And he was very brave in speaking out 'cause Silicon Valley
is full of people desperate to get into Google.
And here he was...
It's would be like an ExxonMobil exec standing up
in 1978 and saying,
hey guys, I think we're gonna melt the Arctic here, right?
It was incredibly brave.
Well, they gave him this sort of lip service role
as ethics officer.
I don't know exactly what-
(indistinct chatter)
Yeah, and he would offer up all these ideas
to align Google's mission with a higher ethic.
But obviously, all of those ideas are in counterpoint
to the objectives of the company itself.
That's exactly it.
What he realized was it's not that they're evil people,
it's not they're bad people.
He realized he was bumping up against
just a very clear logic.
So let's think about Facebook or TikTok or whatever one
we wanna talk about, right?
The business model is extremely simple.
Every time you pick up their phone and start to scroll
they make more money, right?
That's it.
So all of their algorithms,
all of their engineering genius,
all of these super smart people,
all of that human intelligence is applied towards one thing,
figuring out how do we get Rich to pick up
our app more often and how do we get him to scroll
as long as possible, right?
And how do we get Rich's kids to open the app
as often as possible and scroll as long as possible?
That's it.
That's how they make money.
Just like the head of KFC all he cares about
in his capacities as the head of KFC's
is how much fried chicken did Rich eat yesterday, right?
All these companies care about is how often,
how frequently you pick up your phone,
and how long you scroll.
So everything is designed around these two goals.
That's how it works.
But and of course, they've developed...
That means they've developed hundreds of techniques
to figure out how to hack your attention.
And this isn't just the view of dissidents like Tristan,
this is what they say, right?
Sean Parker, one of the biggest initial investors
in Facebook said,
"We designed it to maximally invade people's attention.
We knew what we were doing and we did it anyway.
God only knows what it's doing to our children's brains."
We now know the leaked data,
leaked internal research from Facebook
shows they know they're destroying our collective attention.
They're destroying our political attention.
We can talk about that more.
They know they're doing it and they're continuing to do it.
And the solution to this is you outline, Rich.
If that's when it was explained to me
it seemed almost like weirdly simple, right?
'Cause for so long I thought
oh, the problem is the existence of the smartphone,
and say the problem is in the existence of the smartphone.
The problem is that these devices are currently designed
to maximally invade your attention.
But they don't have to be designed like that.
Just like we have paint that doesn't have lead in it,
you could have social media that is not designed
to maximally invade your attention.
And I remember one of the people who really helped me
to understand this.
I was talking to Aza Raskin one day.
So Aza invented a key part of how many websites work
in the world called infinite scroll.
His dad Jef Raskin,
invented the Apple Macintosh for Steve Jobs.
And Aza said to me,
"Look, the solution here is really simple.
You've got ban the current business model."
That is the equivalent of lead in the lead paint.
Just ban it.
Just say our business model is promised
upon figuring out the weaknesses in your attention
in order to hack it and sell it to advertisers.
It's just inhuman.
It's like lead in lead paint.
It's leading to all sorts of individual disasters
for our attention.
And it's leading to collective political disasters
Just ban it.
And I remember when he said this to me
and lots of other people who I interviewed,
who'd been at the heart Silicon Valley and still are.
(indistinct) saying to them, "Well, I don't understand.
Well, let's say we do that what happens the next day
when I open Facebook?
Would it just go, sorry guys, we've gone fishing?
And he said, "Of course not.
What would happen is these companies would be forced
to move to a different business model."
And absolutely everyone listening to this podcast
has an experience of the two alternative business models.
So one is very simple subscription.
We don't know how HBO and Netflix work.
You pay a little bit and you would get access.
Or another option is one that literally
everyone has access to.
Which is think about the sewers,
before we had sewers we had shit in the streets,
we got cholera.
So we all pay to build the sewers together
and we all own the sewer in common.
You own the sewers where you live,
I own the sewers where I live along with all the other
citizens of where we live.
It may be that like we wanna...
We currently own the sewage pipes together
that we wanna own the information pipes together.
'Cause at the moment we're getting the kind of equivalent
of cholera for our attention.
The most important thing to understand is when you move
to these different business model
all the incentives change.
At the moment the incentive is how do we get Rich to scroll
as often as possible?
How do we get as kids to scroll as often as possible?
'Cause you are not the customer,
you are the product they sell to the real customer
who are the advertisers.
But if you move to this different business model,
suddenly all the incentives are different.
Suddenly they're not how do we invade Rich's attention?
We're like, oh, Rich is our customer now.
What does Rich want?
Oh, Rich wants to be able to pay attention.
Let's let's design it to help him do that.
I'm gonna play a little bit of the counties point to this
devil's advocate because take Netflix for example,
subscription model yet their primary objective remains
to endeavor to get you to spend as much time
on their platform as possible.
That's still the case regardless of whether
there's advertisers involved.
So it's not...
The interesting is if you talk to Netflix people,
or I've got a new streaming series that just came out
on Roku narrated by Samuel L. Jackson called The Fix.
So I spent a lot of time talking
to various streamers about this.
What they care about is not quantity of engagement
but quality of engagement.
So think about if you've got an HBO subscription.
I subscribe to HBO because I love Mare of Easttown,
not 'cause I watch HBO five hours a day.
I don't watch HBO five hours a day.
Subscription services is prioritize quality of engagement.
So they want is some shows that people really love,
which is very different to quantity of engagement.
Netflix doesn't care if you're watching it six hours a day
or one hour a day they care if you resubscribe.
And you're more like to resubscribe
if it makes you feel good cause there's certain
good quality brand leading excellent shows.
So you can see how that's very different.
In the same way think about the changes that would happen
in Facebook if we moved to a subscription based model,
or a kind of public ownership
independent of government model.
And it would be important that it was independent
of government.
So at the moment what Facebook cares about is...
Facebook has won If you spend six hours a day at it, right?
That's the goal, right?
Think about something as simple as
face to face engagement, right?
We know there's overwhelming evidence,
there's a bit of a no Sherlock finding
but there's overwhelming evidence.
People feel good when they look into each other's faces,
they feel better when they're actually face to face
with each other.
We will learn this through the pandemic
how painful it is to be deprived at that.
And they feel less good when they interact
through screens, right?
Okay, we know that.
At the moment, Facebook is all geared towards getting you
to interact through screens, right?
They do not want you to meet up.
It's a disaster for them if you meet up.
If you and me are chatting to each other
through the Facebook algorithm,
they're learning more information
about us to sell to advertisers.
If you say, hey Johann, do you wanna go for a hike?
And I go for a hike with you and we put our phones down.
They lose that data,
they lose that information,
they lose that revenue stream.
So at the moment Facebook is designed to militate
against face to face contact and to maximize
screen-based contact.
Now imagine that we...
You and me with suddenly became the customers
or the owners of Facebook, right?
Through subscription or public ownership.
Suddenly Facebook has a completely different
calculation, right?
It's like, oh, we wanna keep Johann and Rich subscribing
to Facebook.
What could we offer them that would make them
wanna keep using our service?
We could put in a button that says,
which of my friends are nearby and wanna meet up?
And you mark you wanna meet up and I could mark
I wanna meet up.
So it gets to a Thursday afternoon,
you finished your work for the day.
You go, oh, I wanna meet up with someone.
Push the button.
Oh, Rich is around, Joe's around.
Let's go for a hike, right?
Now, you can see how that would mean we would spend
less time on Facebook.
I'd see you wanted to go for a hike,
oh, let's me up, right?
It would be less time but we'd be happier with the product.
We'd have greater quality of engagement
with the product, right?
So that's why subscription is...
Subscription services are always concerned about quality
not quantity of engagement.
Of course, there's-
Yeah, I get that, I get that.
It would be the quality of the experience-
Exactly.
That you experience when you're on the platform
makes it worth spending however much every month.
But the bigger piece being that it obviates
all of this data tracking and avatar building around
what your preferences are and where you go and all of that
so that it could be sold.
And that of course, augers all kinds of
privacy concerns, et cetera.
Which become bigger issues that extend beyond
just our addiction to our phones.
Yes, exactly.
I think you're totally right.
And key thing to understand is at the moment
we're in a race, right?
You've got these 12 factors that are invading our focus
and our attention.
And many of them on the current trajectory
are gonna get worse if we don't act.
So think about Paul Graham,
one of the leading investors in Silicon Valley said,
"The world will be more addictive in the next 40 years
on the current trajectory than it was in the last 40 years."
Think about how much more addictive TikTok is to your kid
than Facebook, right?
So that's one side of the race.
On the other side,
we've gotta have the movement of all of us saying,
no, you don't get to do this to us.
You don't get to do this to our minds,
you don't get to do this to our kids minds.
This is not a good life.
We don't wanna live in a society
where people are constantly switching, switching, switching.
Where we can't have deep conversations,
we can't read books,
we can't slow down and think deeply.
We absolutely can get to a society
where we have restored our ability
to focus and pay attention.
I went to places that had taken huge steps towards that.
New Zealand, France, all sorts of places, but we ha...
It won't happen if we don't fight for it, right?
And of course, I mean, peacefully fight for it
not violently.
We have to take on these forces.
'Cause the current trajectory...
Professor Sune Lehmann,
who's a professor in Denmark who did the first study
proving that our collective ability to pay attention
really is getting worse.
When I went to interview him in Copenhagen,
a few days before there had been this photo
that came out and it's a picture...
A lot of viewers will have seen it.
It's a picture of Mark Zuckerberg
and everyone in the room
is wearing virtual reality headset for the metaverse
except for Mark Zuckerberg
was the only person walking freely.
And Professor Lehmann said to me,
"This is a vision of where we are headed
if we don't fight back."
A world where you've got an elite
who are becoming extremely rich of manipulating us.
And this is not just true of the tech industry.
Food industry, we talked about people who manufacture
these pollutants and many other factors.
And then are kind of mass who are degraded
as Tristan put it.
Where we upgraded technology and downgraded humans.
That people are degraded, debase,
their ability to pay attention is invaded.
We don't have to accelerate.
We don't have to accelerate towards that future,
we don't have to accept that future.
There is another future we can choose.
Whether there are very practical changes that are not crazy,
wild-eyed utopian solutions.
Very practical things that are being done in different parts
of the world where we can choose to live in a slower,
saner way where deep focus is possible.
And I think we have to choose it and fight for it.
Yeah, I mean, I think that it's a battle that has
to be waged on so many different fronts.
And the war that's being fought is something that
is challenging to get your head around.
Because it's not just like lead in gasoline,
or don't drink and drive.
It is a more kind of amorphous situation that infects
our lives in so many different ways.
'Cause it's like the addictive aspects of tech,
the fact that our privacy concerns are invaded.
There's so many...
It's a lot of different tiny little things that add up
to a very big thing.
So the business model, all of the...
All of these different things.
So for the average human being who's like,
I really don't like that.
I'm distracted and I'm worried about my kid.
And this is something worth being concerned about
and fighting for.
Like how do I even wrap my head around
what the solution would be?
Or how I get involved in participating in this?
Well, it's more like feminism.
If you think about my grandmother's, right?
Like I mentioned 1963.
My grandmother's lives were profoundly disfigured by sexism.
They never got to be the people they could
and should have been, right?
Because they were denied systematically opportunities
to develop themselves 'cause they were women.
And feminism, male power ran and runs through
the whole society at every level.
They were...
Every institution in that society
that my grandmothers faced.
But my grandmothers had a pre feminist consciousness, right?
They hated what had been done to them.
They were really pissed off.
Their brothers got to have decent lives and they didn't.
But they just thought that's the way
of the world, right?
That's just...
That's how it's always been.
That's the way of the world.
They didn't have a sense that this was something
that was done to them that could have been different.
And then of course we have a movement
that raises people's consciousness that says to them,
"You know, this didn't have to happen to you.
This wasn't inevitable, right?
Actually, look, we can change this if we want to."
And we have to challenge power all sorts of levels.
And I think we have to do something similar with attention.
So let's think about an example,
something I think that will really connect
with a lot of your listeners and viewers, Rich.
Let's think about the aspects of childhood, right?
So the last quarter of Stolen Focus is about
the ways in which our children's abilities focus is being
catastrophically degraded, right?
And I think most people listening can see that happening
around them in really disturbing ways.
And this is not just the same old,
oh, every generation thinks the next generation's
got a problem.
Professor Larry Rosen did lots of research
where they just look at college students,
these are college students.
And discovered they just can't focus
more than a few minutes, right?
I interviewed a professor at Harvard
who was talking about a specific book,
a little book that we were discussing.
And he said, "I used to give this to our students
to read every term.
And it carried on.
And I went later on I went back and said,
"Oh, why don't you give it anymore?"
Is that writer Thomas Kuhn is his name.
"Is he gone out of fashion?"
And he said, "No, you just...
They just can't read it anymore.
You can't give...
It's like 100 pages.
So they just won't read it.
We give them short articles, we give them podcasts."
I was like, "Shit, that's Harvard students, right?"
You suddenly...
One of those moments,
there's several moments where I kind of thought,
"Oh, shit, does this mean no one can focus anymore?"
If you go to places where you expect there
to be these pockets of focus and they aren't there.
So if we look at children,
'cause I think this is an area
where we could get the biggest
and quickest consensus on one of the changes
that has to happen to get our attention back.
I don't think it's a coincidence that we've had
an explosion in children's attention problems
at the same time as we've had a profound transformation
in the next of childhood itself.
And I tell the story of this in the book
through one of the heroes of the book and one of my heroes,
a woman called Lenore Skenazy,
who you should totally have on the podcast by the way.
So Leno grew up in Chicago...
In a suburb of Chicago in the 1960s.
And from when she was five,
in the morning she would leave the house on her own
and walk to school was about 15 minutes away.
And she would generally bump into the other five year olds
who were also walking to school on their own.
When they got to the school there was a 10 year old boy
whose job was to help the five year olds
across the street, right?
She would go to school, she would leave at three o'clock
and she would wander around the neighborhood on her own.
Play with the other kids, they'd make up games,
figure out whatever they wanted to do.
And she would find her way home at five or six
when she was hungry, right?
Now, remember that was your parents' life.
That was my parents' childhood, right?
That was mine too.
I'm a little...
I'm older than you.
But yeah, I would just go-
(indistinct chatter)
Leave the house in the morning and just be back
by dinnertime and ride my bike around and do whatever.
Who knows what was going on?
And then in the space of one generation all of that ended.
By the time Lenore had her own kids
and she was living in Queens,
in New York in the 1990s.
She was expected to walk her kids to school
and wait at the gate
when they were ready to come back, right?
By 2003, only 10% of American children
ever played outside without adult supervision.
And of that 10%,
I think they got an average of 12 minutes a week.
So effectively long before COVID,
childhood became a phenomenon that happened entirely
behind closed doors, right?
And it turns out that childhood that you had
contains all sorts of things that are really important
for children to learn attention and focus.
One again, it's a bit of a no Sherlock insight
is exercise, right?
Children need to run around.
We are the first human society ever that has tried
to get children to sit still for eight hours a day.
No one's ever tried to do it
'cause it's so obviously foolish.
The evidence is overwhelming,
kids who can't pay attention the single best thing
you can do is let them go and run around, right?
We've stopped children from physically roaming around.
But there's much more than that.
People like Dr. Isabel Behncke,
great Chilean scientist
have shown when children play freely with each other,
they learn how to deploy their attention.
They learn what they find interesting,
they learn how to make things happen with other kids,
they learn how to get other kids to pay attention to them,
how to tolerate waiting for your turn.
All sorts of things
that are completely essential for attention.
And we took that away.
Now kids do play but they play supervised
by adults telling them what to do.
And that's the equivalent.
It's like the demonstrating processed food
and whole foods, right?
Supervised play where adults tell them what to do
doesn't cut it, right?
Yeah, you have that example of that classroom
where they would allow them free time to play.
And the kids didn't know what to do
because they were waiting for somebody to tell them
what tat play should look.
It was heartbreaking.
But the reason why Lenore is...
This is not just a sad story,
but Lenore is one of the hair heroes of the book.
One of several kind of heroes who are building
the solutions and there's many others.
A guy called Andrew Barnes in New Zealand
who found a way to restore attention at work,
a whole range of people.
But the reason Lenore is one of the heroes
is because Lenore runs a group called Let Grow.
That is the solu...
I think the solution to this problem,
or the beginnings of the solution to this problem.
So Lenore was horrified by this change
that happened in childhood.
She could see why it was harmful.
And initially she just tried to persuade individual parents
to let their kids play outside.
So she would go to them and she would often ask them
a question like, "Tell me about something you loved doing
when you were a kid
that you don't allow your own child to do?"
And people would say, "I went into the woods,
I rode my bike by the clips."
We could all think of something, right?
But she found individual persuasion doesn't do it.
'Cause if you're the only parent letting your kid out,
they get frightened, you look crazy.
And actually sometimes people ring the police, right?
They see children on their own now.
So what she did,
she runs this amazing group called Let Grow,
a (indistinct) on every parent and grandparent
go to letgrow.org.
What they do is they go to whole schools
and whole communities and persuade the entire community
to give their children increasing levels of independence,
which rise up to playing freely with other kids
on their own out of their homes.
And I think of all the conversations I had for the book,
there were loads that were really moving.
I think the most moving was with a 14 year old boy
in Long Island, he was part of a Let Grow program.
So this boy, he was a big, strong boy.
He was taller than me, big strong boy.
And until this program had begun,
I think just over a year before he had never been allowed
out of his house, right?
On his own ever.
I asked him why?
His parents didn't even let him go for a jog
around the block.
I asked him why and he said,
"My parent...
I'll never forget this phrase.
He said, "My parents were afraid of all these kidnappings."
To give you a sense,
this boy he lives in a town where the olive oil stores
across the street from the French bakery, right?
And he had a level of fear that would be appropriate
if he lived in Syria.
And then this program began
and he started to play outside his home with his friends
and asked him how it felt
to just be out of his home?
And he described how they played with each other
and then they went into the woods
and they built a fort together.
And he said...
With real shock, he said,
"Our cell phones don't work in the woods
so we still go there."
(Johann and Rich chuckling)
As if that was some mind blowing thing.
And watching this boy speak,
maybe it sounds melodramatic,
but it really did feel like watching a child
come to life, right?
I thought about all the kids
I know who never get to go out and do anything.
The only place we let our children explore anything
is on Fortnite or World of Warcraft.
We can hardly be surprised they become obsessed with them.
And Lenore was with me that day when I spoke to that boy
and when he left she turned to me and she said,
"Think about human history, all of human history,
young people had to go out and explore.
They had to hide, they had to seek, they had to hunt,
they had to build things.
And then we took all that away from them."
And those boys given just a tiny little sliver of freedom,
what did they do?
They went and built a fort.
This is so deep in human nature.
Now I would argue every single school in the United States
should ever Let Grow program.
This costs nothing it's free, right?
It's one of the lowest hanging fruit things
we can do to restore attention.
And it's particularly important
'cause if kids don't learn to pay attention,
they're gonna struggle their whole lives with it.
If you don't learn it in childhood and adolescents,
it's gonna get much harder for you.
But we can hardly be surprised our kids
are surprised with their devices.
If that's the only interesting thing in their life,
if that's the only zone of freedom they ever get, right?
So I think we've really got to do this.
Does that ring true to you, Rich?
Yeah, 100%.
I mean, I think that there's that narrow window of time
where brain plasticity is at it's peak
and that's the same moment where these young people
are enuring themselves to habits around technology
that are basically destroying that ability to concentrate
before they even get out of the gate
and have opportunities to deploy it.
And I think in the case that you just explained,
what I was thinking about was the broader conversation
and issue which is this fear-based society
that is driven by media and technology
because those platforms are incentivized to provoke fear.
So you have a kid who's afraid to go outside,
whose relationship with the outside world
is that of somebody who lives in Syria,
who has an irrational fear of being kidnapped
driven by his parents I'm sure telling him it's not safe.
So where is that coming from?
Well, that's coming from media and technology, right?
So the downstream implications of the at is that
the kid has an unhealthy relationship with the world.
And I think all of this is being fomented by COVID,
which is enhancing this idea that the world
is a scary place.
That if you go outside
and you're not wearing a mask you could die.
Like for a young person that relationship
with the external world is really off the rails right now
in so many ways.
And a lot of your book was written kind of...
You've put pandemic pieces into it.
But really my sense was that the gravamen of it
was researched and written in kind of a pre pandemic state.
I feel like all of these issues that you address in the book
are really even further complicated
by what we've experienced these last two years.
It really prepared me...
Obviously, the last bit of the book is about COVID.
But it really prepared me...
I think the research I did before prepared me
to understand something that happened
to all of us under COVID.
So I remember at the start of the pandemic,
I was actually ill at the start of the pandemic.
I caught COVID before it was fashionable.
And I remember very early lots of people saying...
Those of us who did not have to do the heroic work
of emergency workers and so on.
Saying, "Oh, we're gonna be shot in our homes for a while.
I'm gonna read Todd's Story,
I'm gonna learn French on Duolingo.
And you wanna noticed no one read Todd's Story,
no one learned French, right?
In fact, people Googling how do I get my brain to work
increased by more than 300%.
And I think there's a reason why there is...
There are many reasons why.
But I think one reason
why I think is really worth thinking about.
so I had interviewed...
And I was stress...
she was not talking about COVID.
This is before COVID.
But I interviewed Dr. Nadine Burke Harris,
who's now the surgeon general of California.
And she said something to me that really helped me
to understand this.
She she's done this huge amount of work on the research
on the ways in which stress alters attention.
And she said to me, "Imagine one day you're walking down
the street and out of the blue
you were attacked by a bear and you survive.
In the weeks and months that follow something completely
involuntary will happen to your attention."
You're gonna find it harder to say read a book
because part of your brain will just be
scanning the horizon for dangers, right?
Something came out the blue.
So what else is gonna come out the blue and attack me?
So your brain is scanning.
It's called vigilance, right?
Your brain is more vigilant to risk and danger.
Okay, now imagine the bear attacks you again.
A bear comes back and attacks you again, right?
Likely in the...
And you survive again.
In the aftermath of that you're likely to go
into a state called hypervigilance.
hypervigilance is where you can't focus on things
that are in front of you
'cause you're just...
Your brain is so primed for risk and danger.
Kids who've been through severe trauma very often
are in a state of hypervigilance, right?
There was a child psychiatrist in Australia in Adelaide,
called Dr Jon Jureidini.
Who said something to me about this to help me
to think about this.
He said, "Deep focus is a really good strategy
when you're safe."
Sit down and read a book, you'll grow,
you'll know more stuff you'll be smarter.
Deep focus is a really dumb strategy if you're in danger,
you'd be fool to sit at the Battle of the Somme
reading a novel you're gonna be shot, right?
So when we're plunged into unsafe situations
our attention will flip, right?
It's not that you're not paying attention
but you're paying attention to the detection of risk.
And I think in the situation when with COVID,
there's lots of things that have happened
that affected our attention but the bear came back, right?
The bear came back twice more times.
I think anyone who's struggling to focus
in a global pandemic I would say don't...
it's not your fault, right?
You actually...
What your brain is doing is trying to protect you from risk.
There's the risk of the virus,
there's the risk of the changes to our lives
which have been unprecedented
and extremely weird and disorientating.
There's the risk of our sense of the future
being profoundly disrupted.
There's lots of other factors that have played out
as well that we can talk about.
So I think what's happened is we've been plunged
into a state of hypervigilance.
I also think that can help us to understand
more widely about stress...
What stress in more normal times does to our focus.
Stress really damages your ability to pay attention
which is why I go through lots of things in the book
that we can do to reduce stress us both individually,
and collectively because anything
that reduces stress improves the ability to focus deeply.
Yeah.
Can I mention something
you mentioned before though, Rich about...
Could you come back to you was another thing you said about
the way technology encourages this fear?
Do you mind if I talk a little bit about that?
Yeah.
'Cause that...
It's really important to understand this.
Of all the things I learned this to me
was one of the most revelatory
and helped me to understand a lot of the things
that have happened in the world in the last five years.
So this to a large degree, not entirely,
but to a large degree is the result of what we were talking
about in relation to the business model.
So we've got a business model where the algorithm
are all primed to figure out what will keep
Rich scrolling, right?
That's it.
That's all the algorithm is detecting.
Constantly figuring it out.
What kind of posts keep Rich scrolling,
and what kind of posts make Rich put down the app, right?
Constantly figuring that out.
And unfortunately, and this was not to be fair to them.
The intention of anyone at Facebook, TikTok and these sites,
those algorithms bumped into
a deep human psychological truth.
That's actually been known about by psychologists
more than 100 years.
Which is called negativity bias.
It's very simple.
You will stare longer as something that makes you angry
and upset than you will at something
that makes you feel good.
Anyone who's ever seen a car crash on the highway
knows how that works.
You stared longer at the mango car wreck
than you did at the pretty flowers
on the other side of the street.
This is very deep in human nature.
Eight week old babies will stare longer
at an angry face than a happy face.
It's probably for a very good reason in our evolution.
Our ancestors who were looking out for risk,
got to be our ancestors and the other ones got eaten.
That's a slightly crude way of putting it
but you know what I mean?
But when you have a business model designed
to keep people scrolling that bumps into negativity bias,
it discovers...
It produces a horrific outcome.
So let's imagine two teenage girls who go to the same party
and leave to go home on the same bus.
And one of them does a status update where she says,
that was a great party.
I had a great time, everyone looked good.
And the other teenage girl goes,
Karen was a fucking skank at that party
and her boyfriend's a prick.
(Rich laughs)
And just as a rant against everyone there, right?
The algorithm scans,
it looks of words relating to anger, and outrage.
It'll put the first update into some people's feed,
it'll put the second update into way more people's feed
because it knows if it's enraging, it's engaging,
it will keep people scrolling.
More people go,
what do you mean Karen is skank?
You're a skank.
You can see how conversation will go.
Now that is bad enough at the level of teenage girls on...
We can see what's happening to teenage girls mental health.
Professor Jill Twenge has done very good research...
Sorry, I've said her name wrong.
Professor Jean Twenge has done very good research on this.
But think about that effect when it's applied
to our whole society, right?
When we are all plugged into machinery
that makes us angrier and angrier angrier.
We know what the effect is
'cause we just have to turn on
the news, right?
We've become a society where we can't listen to each other,
where we are constantly screaming at each other,
where everyone is...
The center is collapsing and people are going to greater,
and greater extremes.
When Brazil elected a far right president,
Jair bolsonaro, who's destroying the Amazon rainforest
which will affect us all.
His supporters on election night outside at the rally,
they chanted "Facebook, Facebook, Facebook."
'Cause they knew that the algorithms
had privileged Jair Bolsonaro, boosted him,
massively helped him in one of the key factors,
not the only one in his election.
So you're totally right that negative...
And not only do we know this from the scientists
who studied it, we know it from Facebook themselves.
After the elect...
After the Brexit referendum in Britain
where Britain shockingly voted to leave the European Union,
Facebook got their own internal data scientists...
And after the election of president Trump.
Facebook got own internal data scientists to figure out
did we play a role in the polarization
and the damage to collective attention that led to this?
And what did they find that own data scientists
talked about all these factors.
And they said...
It was really striking what they said.
They said that,
"It was inherent to the current business model
to drive polarization and make people angrier.
And the only solution was for them to abandon
the current business model."
They even warned a third of all the people in Germany
who had joined neo-Nazi groups had joined
'cause Facebook's algorithm had specifically recommended it.
You might want to join it said,
followed by a neo-Nazi group.
Now even when they were told that
Facebook haven't significantly changed their model, right?
So they're not gonna change it on their own anymore
than the lead industry was one day gonna go,
you know what guys I think we've just made enough money,
let's not poison kids anymore.
They had to be made to do it by a movement.
We've got to make these forces...
Of course we can protect ourselves as much as possible.
We've gotta stop these forces.
'Cause you can again see how you
as an individual can opt out of that.
I can go to Provincetown for three months
but I'm still living in a society where everyone else
is being made angrier and angrier and angrier, right?
So even if you can individually protect yourself,
if the effect on the society is so catastrophic
then you've got to be engaged in collective action as well.
Yeah, education is such a big piece in this.
When you were telling that story,
I was reflecting on when Zuckerberg went to testify
before Congress and I can't remember
which Senator or Congressman ask him-
(indistinct chatter)
(chuckles)
How do you make your money?
They don't even understand what the model is,
let alone have the tools or experience to figure out
what's so terribly wrong about what's happening right now
so that we can course correct it.
Yeah, but the thing to understand about that
is Rebecca Solnit, the writer said,
"Politicians are weather veins and it's our job
to be the weather, right?"
Of course, these imbecile senators who are asking
these ludicrous questions.
I mean, it was literally almost like
I can't get into my phone.
(Rich laughs)
Can you tell me the code was the level of the questioning?
They're never gonna...
But think about every change that's ever happened.
It didn't happen because people at the top
suddenly had some awakening one day,
it happened 'cause ordinary people made them do it, right?
Think about, again, when I get pessimistic about this
I'm conscious that we're talking a lot...
I do talk a lot about individual changes
in the book as well.
I'm conscious we're talking a lot about these big changes,
which is absolutely the right place
to drive the conversation.
And I'm conscious that can make a lot of people feel
well, you know...
People listening and watching don't need me to tell them
we're in a culture where it's very hard for us
to do anything collectively.
And I mentioned my grandmothers
but I would give another example
that I go to a lot when I feel pessimistic about this.
So great friend of mine is that writer, Andrew Sullivan.
He's the Andrew that you're...
Yeah, in Provincetown.
I was clear.
I was like that's definitely Andrew Sullivan.
(Johann and Rich laughing)
Yeah, he's an amazing person.
And so in 1994, Andrew was diagnosed as HIV positive
at the height of the aids crisis.
When as far as he knew that was a death sentence,
there was no one thought there was any hope in sight.
His best friend Patrick had just died of aids.
And Andrew thought,
"Well, I'm gonna die in a couple of years.
He quit his job,
he was the editor of The New Republic magazine
and he went to Provincetown to die.
And he decided that before he died
he was gonna one last thing.
He was gonna write a book about a crazy utopian idea
that no one had ever written a book about before.
And he was like, "Look, I'm never gonna live to see
this idea put into practice.
No one alive today is ever gonna live to see it,
but maybe someone somewhere down the line
will pick up this idea."
The idea that Andrew wrote the first book to advocate
for is gay marriage.
And when I get depressed I imagine going back in time
to Provincetown to 1994,
when Andrew was writing his book virtually normal
and saying to him, okay, Andrew,
you're not gonna believe me but 26 years from now
A, you'll be alive, that would've blown his mind.
B, you'll be married to a man, that's gonna be legal.
C, I'll be with you
when the Supreme court of the United States
quotes this book you're writing now.
When it makes it mandatory for every state
in the United States to introduce gay marriage rights.
And the next day you'll be invited
to a white house lit up in the colors of the rainbow flag
to have dinner with the president to celebrate
what you and everyone...
And so many other people have achieved.
Oh, and by the way that president
he's gonna be black, right?
I would've sounded like preposterous.
Like me saying to you so Rich,
26 years from now we'll be invited to smoke crack
with a trans president in the Oval Office, right?
It would've seemed...
Not that we want that.
I mean, the trans president, yes not the crack.
But you can see how that would've seemed ludicrous then.
It happened, it happened because enough people
banded together, they fought for it,
they appealed to other people
in a spirit of love and compassion.
And I absolutely believe this is an easier fight than that.
We had 2000 years of homophobia that had to be overcome.
These problems are really recent, right?
And homophobia dreadful though it is affects a very small
minority of people.
This staff affects everyone to some degree, right?
So the potential coalition is everyone except
Mark Zuckerberg, right?
That's a pretty big coalition.
I absolutely believe we can do this
and I think we need to do it.
Because these trends are getting worse. Right?
Do we wanna be in a position where a few is right now
we look back nostalgically on the time
when the average American office worker focused on
only one task for three minutes, right?
There's a limit beyond which we can't go.
So I am optimistic about the capacity to fight back on this,
but we have to decide to do it, right?
It's not gonna just passively happen.
No Messiah...
No attention Messiah is gonna come to save us.
We have to do this ourselves.
Yeah, beautifully put but I think it's important
to understand that there is a level of apathy around this
because it's almost as if we've been all cajoled
into this waking dream.
We've all voluntarily signed up
for this level of enslavement.
And many of us are only nominally conscious
of what's even happening let alone the dangers
that this presents.
And I think there's a lot of people who are just like,
I don't care.
I just like...
I like to scroll.
It's the only thing in my life that's gives me
any kind of satisfaction because my job sucks
and I'm at home and I'm on Zoom all day
and I can barely pay my bills
and I just wanna be able to go on Facebook and...
Or go on Reddit and join my community where I feel like
I'm part of something because otherwise
I feel terribly alone.
I think this...
Marc Maron, the comedian said,
"Every Facebook status update could be boiled down
to the underlying sentiment.
Will someone somewhere please acknowledge I exist."
And I think you've gone to a layer of the conversation.
I'm really glad you bring that up, Rich.
And this relates to the book we talked about last time,
my previous book's Chasing the Scream and Loss Connections,
which are about addiction and depression.
Right, there's this irony with Loss Connection
and what you're talking about now.
Because what's driving all of this
is this desire to be connected.
And it is that impulse that ultimately is driving us apart
and putting distance between us
and the connection that we seek.
I think what we're getting
is a kind of parody of connection.
So I went to the first ever internet rehab center
in the world it's outside Spokane in Washington State.
It's called reSTART Washington,
it's great place.
And I spent a lot of time talking,
they get all kinds of people there
but they disproportionate to get young men.
And that often young men have become obsessed
with either porn or multi-player online role playing games.
And it was essentially speaking to these young men
and then later going out with Dr. Hilarie Cash
is the co-founder of this place.
And her saying to me,
"You've gotta ask yourself
what do these young men get out of these games?"
They getting something they used to get from the society
but they no longer get, right?
They're getting a sense they physically roam around, right?
As we said we young people
don't get that particularly during COVID but even before.
They get a sense they're good at something.
We have created a society where young men are made
to feel incompetent by the school system.
They don't feel they're good at anything.
And they get a feeling that people see them, right?
Other people are watching you when you're playing the game.
This profoundly lonely society,
41% of Americans agree with the statement.
No one knows me well.
But I think what they're getting
is a kind of parody of connection.
And it was interesting talking to them...
Talking to her about this after I've been speaking
to these young men about how they're obsessed with porn.
Because in a way I think the relationship between
social media and social life is a bit like
the relationship between porn and sex, right?
I'm not anti porn, porn on me is certain basic itch.
But if your entire sex life consisted of jerking off
over porn you'd be going around kind of off and irritated
a lot of the time because we didn't evolve to jerk off
over screens we evolved to actually have sex.
And no one feels satisfied after they've spent an hour
looking at Pornhub compared to how they feel
after an hour of having sex at least if it goes right.
And in a similar way,
there's a misalignment between
as this appeals to the part...
Just like porn appeals to the part of us
that wants to have sex.
This stuff appeals to the part of us
that is craving connection,
but it offers us a kind of misaligned parody of it.
But this connect to a wider thing...
The first thing you and I ever talked about, Rich
when we first met.
Which is about addiction, right?
So the deeper thing you're getting at those people saying,
"This is all I've got."
I think this is...
That's really true which is why part of what's happening
is that this technology addiction is a symptom of...
I would argue all addiction to some degree.
The core of addiction is about not wanting
to be present in your life
'cause your life is too painful
a place to be, right?
That's true.
Whether you're addicted to gambling, heroin,
alcohol, whatever it might be.
And we've talked before,
but I think it's worth thinking about this in relation to...
So obvious;y, I wrote a book called Chasing The Scream
and I gave a Ted Talk about this.
That we had a lot of addiction in my family
which is why this was so important to me.
And my...
The three years I spent researching addiction
which actually started exactly 10 years ago
which blows my mind.
My whole attitude towards addiction was profoundly
transformed by a scientist I got to know and love,
a man named Professor Bruce Alexander.
So let's talk about...
Let's choose her in addiction
'cause that was close to me.
If you had asked me when I started doing the research
for Chasing The Scream,
what causes heroin addiction?
I would've looked at you like we're full.
And I would've said,
well, Rich the clues in the name, right?
Obviously heroin causes heroin addiction.
We've been told this story for 100 years
that's become totally part of our common sense.
It was...
I mean, I thought I'd literally seen it play out
in front of my eyes.
We think if we kidnapped the next 20 people
to walk past this studio here in LA and
we injected the all with heroin every day for a month,
like a villain in a Saw movie.
At the end of that month they'd all be heroin addicts
for simple reason.
This chemical hooks in heroin
that their bodies would start
to desperately physically crave
and at the end of that month they'd have this tremendous
physical hunger for the drug, right?
That's why we call it being hooked, right?
It's a craving for the chemical hooks.
It turns out...
That's true chemical hooks are real,
but they're a very small part of what's going on
in addiction.
And one of the ways we know that there's many reasons,
but this was discovered by a man named
Professor Bruce Alexander who I interviewed in Vancouver,
who changed my life actually.
And Professor Alexander explained to me,
this story we have in our heads about addiction
that it's caused primarily or entirely
by the chemical hooks comes primarily
from a series of experiments
that were done earlier in the 20th century.
They're really simple experiments.
Your viewers can try them at home
if they're feeling a little bit sadistic.
You probably shouldn't.
You take a rat, you put it in a cage
and you give it two water bottles.
One is just water and one is water laced
with either heroin or cocaine.
If you do that the rat will try both,
it'll almost always prefer the drug water
and almost always kill itself by overdosing
within a couple of weeks.
So there you go, that's our story.
The rat tries the drugs,
gets adapted to the chemical hooks,
once more and more of them kills itself.
But Professor Alexander came along in the 70s
and said, "Hang on a minute,
you put the rat alone in an empty cage.
It's got nothing that makes life meaningful
for rats except these drugs?
What would happen if we did this differently?"
So he built a cage that he called Rat Park,
which is basically heaven for rats.
They've got lots of friends,
they've got lots of cheese.
They can have lots of sex.
They've got lots of colored balls.
Anything a rat finds meaningful in life
is there own Rat Park.
And they've got both the water bottles,
the normal water and the drug water.
And course, they try both.
This is the fascinating thing in Rap Park
they don't like the drug water.
They hardly ever use it.
None of them ever use it compulsively.
None of them ever overdose.
So you go from almost 100% compulsive use and overdose
when they don't have the things
that make life worth living
to no compulsive use and overdose
when they do have the things that make life worth living.
This is why (indistinct) talk about
how the opposite of addiction is connection.
But if we apply that to what you are talking about
you're absolutely right.
There's a lot of people who are in the equivalent
of that first cage.
The only thing they've got in this analogy,
they're in the isolated cage and they've got
not the drug water but the phone, right?
Which at least is something, some connection
to the world, right?
So you're absolutely right.
We've gotta deal with these factors around the technology
and the wider factors that are lowering our immune system
that could resist the technology.
But we've also gotta deal with a society
where most people don't wanna be present, right?
Where everyone watching knows they have
natural physical needs.
Obviously, you need food, you need water,
you need shelter, you need clean air.
If I took those things away from you,
you be in real trouble real fast.
But there's equally strong evidence that all human beings
have natural, psychological needs.
You need to feel you belong,
you need to feel your life as meaning and purpose,
you need to feel that people see you and value you,
you need to feel you've got a future that makes sense.
And this culture we built is good at lots of things,
I'm glad to be alive today.
Where we've been getting less and less good
at meeting these deep underlying psychological needs.
And of course, that will create a culture
where a lot of people can't bear to be present
and they will look for ways to not be present.
And for some of them it'll be opioids.
We can look at the where the places
that have the highest level of opioid addiction.
There are places where there is depression is highest,
where people are have been deprived at their needs most.
For some people it'll be porn,
for some people it'll be obsessively being on TikTok,
for some people it'll be cocaine.
But we have to get to the core
of why they don't wanna be present in their life.
All addiction is a symptom of a wider problem, right?
So I think you're absolutely right.
It's why in a way I think Stolen Focus needs
to be put together with my previous book Lost Connections,
and the one before that Chasing The Scream.
It's why I sort of think of them as a kind of weird trilogy,
which makes me sound like I'm saying I'm George Lucas,
which I know it sounds weird.
But you know what I mean?
That I think there's connections between all these things.
Yeah, I mean, there is a matrix there.
Mental health addiction and our ability to be present
in our lives which is what focus is in many ways,
or a subset of it is yeah.
Are certainly interdependent.
But can I kind of think something
you said before though.
Rich, I just wanted to say...
Promise a very short thing.
So you said that people are apathetic
and I totally understand why you said that.
I think it's slightly different.
It reminds you of something the writers Susan Sontag
said once.
She was talking about compassion fatigue in...
She was talking about the history of when people
see photographs of atrocities in wars, right?
And a lot of people say,
"Oh, you know...
At first when people saw images from Auschwitz,
they were completely shocked.
But now we've got compassion fatigue
from looking at these images.
And she said,
"It's not the compassion that causes the fatigue,
it's the sense that there's nothing you can do about it."
If you think there's nothing you can do about it,
then you become apathetic and numb.
But if you feel that you can do something about it,
actually you get as upset as the first time
you saw it, right?
And the same way...
So I think you're right that we're apathetic,
but we're apathetic
'cause we don't feel we have any agency.
And I'm trying to say to people,
we absolutely do have agency over this.
I think the agency issue is important.
I mean I think how do I say this?
I think your analogy to Rat Park and addiction
with respect to people's relationship
with technology is apted.
Although I would push back a little bit
and I think I did last time we talked about addiction.
I think that the Rat Park study
and analogy is limited in certain respects.
I think addiction is a lot more complicated than that.
I mean, everyone agrees with that.
Yeah, of course, it's too simplistic to say,
all right, if I'm too healing connected to people
then I'm not gonna choose cocaine.
I've spent 25 years (chuckles) in recovery and have seen
a lot of people who work very hard
to create those connections that have been lost
and still struggle and relapse
and don't find their way back-
Totally, and it's not just about being connected to people
it's being about connected to all of your
psychological needs here.
Yes, but I do think you're absolutely correct
in that people feel they don't have agency.
And part of that lack of agency is being fueled
by a lack of opportunity.
So layered on top of that COVID
and all the kind of duress
that hat has exposed us to.
I think there's legions of people out there
who feel somewhat hopeless and really struggle
to find something that they can connect with
that gives their life
a sense of meaning, purpose, and direction.
And it's tricky.
People say, "I don't know what my passion is?
I don't know what my purpose is?
I try this, I try that.
I can't really find it."
It's very difficult to guide that person.
And I think it's somewhat...
what's the right word?
Not irresponsible, but just sort of insufficient
to just say, well, try a bunch of things,
or I trust you that you'll find it.
And I think what happens over time with COVID
really truncating people's ability to kind of explore
other avenues for their life is that there
is a sense of desperation that ensues
that makes it even more difficult
to lift yourself out of that fog or put the phone down,
or stop playing the game or get off the porn.
And it becomes this prison that becomes very difficult
for people to break out of.
I think that's true.
And I think we have to look at
the deeper reasons for that.
So if we think about...
We just talked about really important one, Rich,
which is about our ability to create meaning,
and find meaning.
And I think there's a kind of structural thing
that's happening to us
which is the destruction of our ability to....
Or the profound corrosion of our ability
to construct meaning.
And I wrote about this in Lost Connections
and we touched on it a little bit last time we spoke
but everyone knows that junk food has taken over our diets
and made us physically sick, right?
As you can see from my chins I'm not immune to that myself.
But a kind of junk values have taken over our societies
and our minds have made us mentally sick.
There's a guy called Professor Tim Kasser,
who's at Knox collagen in Illinois, retired now.
Who did lots of research on this.
So for 1000s of amazing research on it.
For 1000s of years philosophers said,
If you think life is about money and status
and showing off you're gonna feel like, right?
It's not an exact quote from Confucius,
but that's basically what he said.
But weirdly nobody had scientifically investigated
this until Professor Kasser
did a huge amount of research into it.
And he discovered that the philosophers were right.
That the more you think life is about money
and status and showing off,
the more likely you are to become depressed and anxious
by a really significant amount.
But what's happened is as a society,
we have become much more driven by those beliefs
in the last 40 years, right?
I mean, they dominate things like Instagram.
Think about the values of Instagram,
what they are?
The implicit values of Instagram.
But they dominate the whole society.
You talk to kids what's your goal?
"I wanna be a billionaire."
"Would you you wanna be millionaire?
"Just wanna be a billionaire, right?"
We've been taught...
it's almost like we've been fed a kind of KFC for the soul.
We've been trained to look for happiness
in all the wrong places through
working hard at jobs we don't like,
to buy shit we don't need,
to display it on social media to make people jealous.
And so people have been given a script
for how to be happy, right?
That's what we're told makes you feel good.
They do it, it doesn't make them feel good.
And they're like,
"Well, there must be something wrong with me
'cause I'm doing the stuff you're meant to do to be happy."
And at some level we know this isn't true, right?
No one watching thinks they're gonna lie on their death bed
and think about all the likes they got on Instagram
and all the shoes they bought, right?
That's not gonna be.
You're gonna think about moments of love
and meaning and connect.
And something that really helped me during COVID,
was learning from an experiment that Professor Kasser did
with a colleague of his Nathan Dungan.
And it's something I really recommend everyone do
if they were interested in that rediscovery in meaning
that you're talking about that's so important.
There's lots of things we can do about this
but this is one example.
So Nathan was a...
And he is a financial advisor in Minneapolis,
and he was...
So he advises people on like household budgets.
And he was contacted one day by a school,
a kind of middle class,
high school in Minneapolis.
And they said, "Look, we've got a real problem.
We need some help."
The kids at that school were becoming obsessed
with getting the latest Nike sneakers, the latest iPhone.
And often their parents couldn't afford it
and the kids were just losing their shit
if they couldn't get it, right?
And they said, "Will you come in
and explain budgeting to these kids?"
So he came in and quickly realized these kids
didn't give a shit about budgeting, right?
(chuckles)
He would explain budgeting and they'd be like,
"Yeah, whatever I need the iPhone."
And so what he did was a different experiment.
He learned about Professor Kasser's work
and teamed up with him.
And they did this really interesting experiment.
They got the kids and their parents to come to meetings.
I think if I remember rightly it was once
every couple of weeks for six months.
And the first time they met, they literally said to them,
"Just write a list of everything you've got to have."
And they didn't define what that meant.
People said, "What does it mean?"
They say, "Do whatever you think that means."
And of course, everyone says, first you need food.
You need house, whatever home.
But quite quickly people started to name things
you haven't gotta have like the latest iPhone,
the parents would often name things
that no reasonable person has to have, right?
Then they said to them, "Describe how you would...
Your life would be different if you got this thing."
So let's say the kids who talked about Nike sneakers,
how much they wanted the Nike sneakers.
What's interesting is none of the kids
gave the apparent reason for Nike sneakers.
None of them said, oh, I'm a basketball player
and I wanna be able to jump high.
No one said that.
They said things like, "Well, if I got the sneakers,
people would envy me."
people want me to be in, in their group, right?
Doesn't take long to get people to say this out loud
before they realize, oh,
who put that idea in your head
that having a little blue tick on your shoe
means you deserve to have friends, right?
But what's the most interesting bit was what happened next,
where they said to them, "Okay, write about...
Just discuss among yourselves and write about
a moment in your life
when you've had a sense of meaning and purpose."
Different people name different things, right?
We can...
I'll just say anyone watching just picture something now.
And they talked about it.
Whether it was taking their kids to the beach, writing,
playing music, whatever it might be.
And then he said, "Well, how can you build more of your life
around these moments of meaning and purpose
and less around the junk values,
which I think are a bit like junk food.
That we are kind of inculcated
in this culture all the time?"
And what was fascinating was,
so they just met every couple of weeks
and talked about their progress in moving away
from the junk values
and towards meaningful values.
And what they found was just having these conversations.
We don't have these conversations very often in our culture,
just having these conversations led to a marked move
in people's values, right?
It really worked.
And the reason I mentioned that in relation
to what you're saying, Rich is throughout COVID,
in fact, before COVID but during COVID as well.
So once month I have two of my friends
and first day of the month
we just have these conversations.
We talk about what happened in the last month
that was meaningful and what were times
when you were diverted onto junk values
and what in the next month do you wanna look for?
And obviously, we've been doing it on Zoom
'cause of the plague.
And even now I really feel it, right?
I've got this book that just came out, right?
And I can totally feel there's two sets of values
I can get into.
I can get into, oh, I think the things I learned
for Stolen Focus will help people, right?
And I think if other people learn about this
we can change things and make the world better.
When I think about that I feel really good.
I go, "Oh, yeah, I met these amazing people.
I just told Rich about Lenore.
Lenore is an amazing person.
I feel really glad.
Hope people go and look up Lenore
and join her group, right?
That makes me feel good.
Or I can get into who's buying the fucking book?
What do the reviews say, right?
Who are the famous people who tweeted about it, right?
And when I get into that zone I feel like shit
even when the news is good, right?
Even when it's I or a book selling really well
and this famous person just tweeted (indistinct)
even then feel like shit
because that's a junk value, right?
It's not...
It doesn't mean anything, right?
Whereas the meaningful stuff is,
oh, this person might be helped by this thing.
that's meaningful.
The ego stuff is not gonna help me, right?
But the problem is the ego stuff
and the junk value stuff is so intoxicating.
It's the difference.
It's the way that it has the pull and the allure
of the junk food where the fruits
and the vegetables don't give you...
(Johann laughs)
There isn't like that magnetic pull to them
and that's the war that you have to wage
and that's the battle.
I think there's two thing...
There's two layers to that isn't there.
You're totally right.
There's a degree to which this is just a perennial
human problem that will always exist, right?
There's always the temptation of ego
and the temptation of meaning, right?
More meaningful things.
But I also think that the way Professor Kasser
put it to me is,
"We live in a machine that is designed
to get us to neglect what is important about life."
So there's all this evidence, exposure to advertising
makes you more egotistical, right?
We are bombarded with advertising.
More 18 month old children know what the McDonald's M means,
they know their own last name in this country, right?
So you think about from when we're very young,
we've fed this script.
Says a degree to which is a perennial human problem
it will always be a problem and always a struggle.
But then in the environment in which we currently live,
we are loaded towards the bad choice, right?
Whether it's junk food, the constant distraction,
or the junk values,
we're we are living in an environment
that is pushing us in so many ways towards the things
that at some level we know are not good for our attention,
our depression, our addiction.
Yeah.
Well, let's pivot.
We gotta land this plane in a few minutes here.
So let's pivot to some things that people can do
who are struggling with this.
And I think this is a universal thing,
especially parents who are watching their kids
and feel powerless around like how do I get my kid
to put this thing down and get them outside?
How do I take better control of my own habits?
We can fight the war on the systemic front
but what can I do now in today that could improve
the quality of my life?
So yeah, maybe some things
that people can take home and implement.
So I go through dozens of things in the book.
I would say, buy a kSafe.
These people should start paying me commission
(Rich laughs)
because like-
They should make a special Johann Hari kSafe.
(Johann laughs)
that's like branded for you.
With my face on it.
Genius, love that.
Yeah, buy a kSafe and crucially model
the good behavior for your kids, right?
Every night all of you sit down for dinner
and all of you put your phones in the kSafe, right?
And lock it away for an hour.
It's really difficult at first, right?
I won't watch a film with my boyfriend
unless we are both imprison our phones like I said before.
But I'll tell you what-
Teenage daughters now.
The pleasures of focus-
Teenage daughters.
Yeah.
Johann.
(laughs)
They can take an hour...
I've got my niece believe I've had this fight with her.
But the pleasures of focus are so much greater
than the pleasures of this bullshit, right?
It's a muscle you have to strengthen.
So I would say buy kSafe,
install Freedom on your laptop.
It will cut you off either from specific websites.
Say you've got a problem with Twitter,
or from the entire internet.
I've got Twitter permanently blocked on my phone,
I can never look at it.
I have an assistant where if I want to send text,
I tweets, I send them to hers.
I treat it like a radioactive zone,
like Chernobyl or something.
I don't go near it, right?
Or very rarely.
I say by install Freedom on your phone,
change the way you eat.
If you eat oatmeal in the morning,
your attention will be much better than if you eat...
My breakfast of a sausage and Egg McMuffin, right?
So change the way...
Prioritize sleep, right?
Sleep is the single best thing you can do
for your attention.
When you're sleeping, you're repairing.
Let your brain repair.
Massively prioritize sleep.
There's a...
Dr. Czeisler told me a really interesting piece of research
has really helped me.
It's called this...
It's about it...
It's something he discovered.
It's called the second surge of energy.
So human beings evolved so that when it gets dark,
we get a surge of energy.
And you can see the obvious reason in evolution.
You're out, it gets dark you get a surge of energy.
You'll be able to get back to your cave better
than if you didn't, right?
If you didn't get that surge of energy.
But problem is 'cause of artificial light,
we now control the light, right?
So we control when it gets dark.
So if you lie in your bed like most 90% of Americans
look at glowing screen within two hours are going to sleep.
Well, that means is you're lying in your bed
and you switch off your phone
and it suddenly gets dark.
What your body hears is it got dark,
give him a surge of energy.
He needs to get back to his cave.
Your body doesn't know you're already in your cave,
you're in your bed, right?
So really restrict the amount of artificial light
you are exposed to in the two hours where you go to sleep.
And the way I discipline myself to do that
is I put my phone kSafe,
sorry to (indistinct) on about this.
But 'cause if I'm lying there in bed and I'm like,
oh, shit there was that one email.
I should have answered it.
It's very hard in that moment to restrain yourself.
If you've locked the phone away,
you'd either go, one email?
I guess I'll have to answer it tomorrow morning then.
Not the end of the world, right?
I'm not the president of the United States
so I don't need to give orders of Russia invades Ukraine.
The world can wait for me.
I would say that.
And obviously I go through many, many things.
But yeah, there's all sorts of things,
very practical changes that we can make in our lives
right away that can do that.
I would say when you get...
when you can't focus don't go into the spiral
of recrimination that I used to do.
Why are you lacking in willpower?
Why aren't you strong enough?
Instead the conditions for a flow state, right?
Set yourself aside from it,
create the conditions for a flow state
that we talked about before.
So there's all sorts of really big changes
that we can make in our own individual lives
that will hugely help.
And the great thing about that is it's a bit like
the pleasure you get when you lose weight.
Which is you really start to see the benefit, right?
You see the benefits very quickly
and the pleasures of focus are so great.
You get to have proper conversations
where you look into people's eyes and listen to them.
You get to read books,
you get to think deeply about the world.
You get to let your mind wander
and when your mind wanders,
it processes things that happen in the past,
anticipates the future.
It makes sense, it's these connections between things.
These are such deep human needs
that we've been deprived of.
People can feel this is stunting our lives.
And when you try the alternatives even tentatively,
it's hard.
I talked about the crash I had in Provincetown.
It's hard but when you get through that initial hump,
that challenge, the benefits are enormous.
Focus is essential to having a good life.
If you are starved of focus, like we said before
it's so much harder to achieve your goals in life.
Attention is like a form of light
that illuminates your life.
When you get to it's an amazing feeling.
Beautifully put.
Hooray.
I love it.
One thing though can somebody please invent
a better dumb phone than the Jitterbug?
(Johann laughs)
Because I would buy that thing.
Like somebody...
Like all I want on my phone,
I need be able to make phone calls,
I would like to listen to audio books, podcasts, and music,
and maybe like a map for navigation,
and that's maybe kind of it.
So like no app store.
It doesn't seem that hard.
You can sort of do that with your smart phone now,
If you instructed Freedom-
But cheat all these hoop you gotta jump through.
It's like set up like, oh, lock it in here and do...
It's insane that we have to do all of these things
to protect ourselves from ourselves.
I totally agree.
And to fair to the Jitterbug,
it will alert the nearest hospital if you fall over.
(Rich laughs)
You left that out that crucial factor.
I did actually weirdly feel safe even though
I have never fallen over obviously,
'cause I'm like 43
I'm not 90 but yeah so don't diss the Jitterbug too hard.
But I agree with you entirely.
I think there's a lot of people out there
that would buy a phone like that.
They judge like a couple things that you kind of
in a utilitarian way you kind of need.
But without all the stuff that's driving us mad.
Totally agree with you.
But there must be lots of inventors who watch your...
You have lots of tech aud...
A big tech audience.
I don't know.
(indistinct chatter)
Somebody's already invented it
and I just don't know about it.
We should go on Shark Tank and pitch it.
There you go.
I know Mark Cuban.
We can do it.
Okay.
(Johann chuckles)
Are you going back to Vegas?
What do you...
Let's just end this with like you've been living in Vegas?
I spent a lot of the pandemic in Vegas.
I'm writing a book about a series of crimes
that are happening in Vegas.
I've been researching it for 10 years.
Happening now or did happen?
I'm not meant to talk about it too much,
I'll get tased by my publishers if I talk about it.
But it's a series of horrific crimes
that have been happening for some time in Vegas
and I've been researching it for 10 years.
That gives you a sense of how long.
And it's been a very weird place to spend the pandemic
I was saying to you before because and partly
'cause you're surrounded by people whose response
to a global pandemic is to say,
"Well, this is the perfect time to go to Vegas."
So I mean, I love Vegas.
It's an incredible place.
And the people there who I'm writing about
are people are very close to my heart
and very special people to me.
So it's been some of the most amazing people I've ever met.
And so yeah, I'm going to Vegas tomorrow.
I'm flying back to Vegas.
Wow.
It's Viva Las Vegas, baby.
(Johann laughs)
I would need a kSafe for my soul.
I love that.
Thanks Rich, it's always a joy to talk to you.
Thank you so much.
My pleasure.
Thank you.
(gentle music)